Ronda santus is deploying up to 1,000
more National Guard to the Texas border
amid the crisis between the federal
government and the illegal immigrants in
the state of course saying that if you
don't have a border you don't have a
country so of course naturally the
conversation is continuing I don't know
that this is a dramatic escalation it is
serious that Ronda Sanz has B come out
and said we're going to send more but
many states have already sent National
Guard Greg Abbott said 10 different
states sent either state law enforcement
or National Guard so it's hard to know
exactly where this is going but another
grain of sand is being added to that
Heap so we'll talk about that of course
we have uh many on the left saying that
the Republican or right-wing threat of
civil war is serious writing many
articles about to go along with this now
we have another story we covered this
last night undercover footage showing
what appeared to be an army guy of some
sort guarding a room full of illegal
immigrants we have more information on
this some rumors and uh uh some articles
it is true that there has been an effort
since last year or longer to enlist
non-citizens into the Armed Forces
Vladimir Putin is considering the exact
same thing and several countries have
begun re uh reinstating the draft so
while you have many people concerned
about a potential World War III while
you have Joe Biden approving strikes on
Iranian targets and then you have
countries considering the draft I have
to wonder what the US would do in that
circumstance considering gen Z is not
going to fight they're not going to find
very many quality soldiers among the Gen
ZZ generation and so maybe it is that
they're going to start recruiting
non-citizens and we've got the Articles
showing the bills they have tried to put
forward to make this happen so we'll
talk about that plus a whole lot more
looks like Donald Trump right now if the
election were to happen today he would
win and that's bad bad news for Joe
Biden but uh what can they do about it
before we get started my friends head
over to cast brew.com to buy the best
cup of coffee you've ever had
everybody's favorite Appalachia kns is
completely sold out man we sold too much
too quick so you know we had we had to
have a talk with our distributor and say
guys we got to we got to pick up we got
to carry more it's moving too quick but
my friends rise with Roberto Jr the
second most popular because it's got
Roberto Jr right on the bag rest in
peace is available if you go to
casper.com support the show support our
work and uh support our physical
location which we will be doing a show
at March 5th and then the actual uh
coffee venue will uh the coffee shop
will be open I believe around June but
you know we'll see how things work out
also don't forget head over to
timcast.net
bucks a month goes a long way it helps
us produce documentaries you can see
right on the front page you got
infringed by Lauren Southern it helps us
produce basically everything all the
cultural Endeavors so if you like the
work we do you want to see more of it
become a member and you'll get access to
our uncensored membersonly show we'll
have one up for you tonight at 10 p.m.
so smash that like button subscribe to
this channel share the show with your
friends joining us tonight to talk about
this and actually not talk back at all
is Mr Bokus who is currently sitting in
Hannah Clair's La yes it's it's bcus and
I over here just controlling the show
controlling the media that's his way in
life so Mr bcus will be joining us
tonight because we had a little Health
scare with him earlier he got overly
excited because you know he normally
just sits by the door he's been very
sick for a very long time we've been
giving him a lot of medicine keeping him
alive Mr books of course is a cat for
those that aren't aren't watching but uh
he got very sick he wet himself
collapsed and could not move and so
everybody got really scared and as we
are doing pre-production for the show he
made his way up here to hang out and of
course we will not deny him so he'll be
hanging out tonight but the real guest
of course is Brandon stro Mr Boke has
got a little bigger Fanfare I think
absolutely well could be I also wet
myself and collapsed before I got here
no no no but I understand a copier oh my
go I know I know I know it's pathetic
but no no no I I I'm very happy to have
him joining us tonight he he's a sweet
kitty so who are you what do you do oh
yeah so I'm Brandon stro uh the founder
of the walkway campaign um moving to
people walking away from the Democratic
party and we just relaunched on Facebook
too so wow yeah you can go to join walk
away.com and join because we just uh got
started once again right on well thanks
for hanging out we've got Hann Clair of
course she is giving love to Mr bcus yes
I'm Hannah Clair rmma I'm the official
Bokus minder I guess right now no I'm
I'm a writer for sr.com at scanner news
thank you guys for supporting all our
work we have Shane with us tonight again
what's up it's good to be back Shane
Cashman also a writer for cnr.com author
of The inverted World Series it's good
to be here Serge what's up yo uh just
here wearing my favorite top Lobster
merch and uh hanging out with bcus I
guess all right let's roll we got the
story from cnr.com Governor Ronda santis
deploys National Guard to Texas border
quote if we don't have a border then we
are not a sovereign country DeSantis who
ended his 2024 campaign two weeks ago
has promised to deploy at least at least
1,000 troops to the US Mexico border in
addition to the National Guard this will
Mark the first deployment of the Florida
State guard so that's that's distinct I
suppose that's where we're actually
starting to see some escalation Florida
State guard my understanding they're you
can't uh federalize them no they're
separate they're state so this is where
things are starting to get particularly
interesting the concern with Texas
National Guard being deployed is that
Joe Biden could invoke the Insurrection
act or just make some Declaration of we
can't enforce the law without your help
one of the criteria for federalizing a
guard is they can't enforce the law
through other means which could mean he
doesn't need to go and say oh Texas are
in state of rebellion he could just be
like we we love Texas but we're going to
need some help on that border so now
they're under my command but the Texas
state guard and the Florida state guard
not so much so with Ronda sandis
deploying Florida State guard down there
this will create a contingent that
cannot be federalized and this will
solidify I guess State Supremacy on the
law or the states than starting to get
interesting this could end here or this
could contribute to a
larger you know look the federal
government is supposed to be of the
states the states go to the federal
government and the federal government is
formed basically like Captain Planet all
the states say you know with our
Senators combined we get boom federal
government sort of now it's basically
like yeah we do not see you as in charge
and we are going to take it upon
ourselves to unite come together and
effectively form what the government was
supposed to be on their own so they say
uh according to the article desandis
visited Tex uh Texas Mexico border July
of 2021 he sent both state law
enforcement officers and members of the
Florida National Guard to assist he also
sent 800 soldiers 200 Florida Department
of Law Enforcement Officers 101 state
troopers and 20 Wildlife enforcers I'm
sorry Wildlife officers to assist Texas
border patrol in May of 2023 as well as
five planes 17 drones two command
vehicles and 10 boats quote Biden has
the authority to close the border today
if he wanted to he lacks the will to get
the job done he lacks the capacity to
see the problem for what it is so the
American people are basically left
scrambling it's kind of sad I got to be
honest that uh Ron W if if he was just
doing this while running he didn't need
to campaign at all that was the wild
thing about listening to the speech
today which is it's just a totally
different energy I feel like his we we
had campaign Ron and now we have
Governor Ron de santis and and they're
you know he's much more confident he
speaks much more directly um all the
criticisms that he of personality you
couldn't say that here and again this is
something that I think he feels very
confident he's been sending support to
Texas since
2021 uh you know different amounts at
different times he sent boats he sent
people he spent Wildlife agents I mean
he has really reached into every
capacity of the Florida government to
say we're behind controlling the Border
um I I think this is a good move for him
in a lot of ways I think you know
personally I think supporting Texas and
what they're doing is great but I also
think generally he is really putting him
back out there as the governor people
remembered him as there's a meme you
know the meme where it's the guy poking
the stick at the things and he's like
come on do something yeah it's Carl Marx
wearing a mask with a with a smiley face
and KL Marx is crying behind it and he's
poking Texas and Joe Biden is's like
come on do a civil war so here's an
article from New Republic maa's ugly new
Civil War Fantasy should be taken
seriously it's funny
because on the right for the most part
everyone's saying like no Civil War and
the left is saying boy they sure do want
a civil
war like you keep asking us I guess
we'll get it started no it's wild no the
left wants the Civil War to start
because then they can suspend the
Constitution no I think so too I think I
think the what what the you know
Republican L States is are already doing
is just saying well we don't consent to
being governed this way and so we will
resist I mean that was what I thought
was so powerful about the message that
uh Abbott put out saying our right to
self-defense is the supreme law of the
land and nothing supersedes that that's
the way this works and then every other
state that was like yes we completely
agree every other state that felt like
State sovereignty is ultimately
important step forward and it's
obviously not that surprising that it's
along uh partisan lines at least to me I
think Democratic states feel ultimately
that the the more uh concentrated and
the closer the relationship to the
federal government the more power they
have but that's that's not the case
these states are Banning together and
saying we don't want this and we're
going to act accordingly in a nonviolent
way while Tim was reading the list of
everything that disantis is sending to
Texas I had this terrible image of the
federal government stopping it in some
similar fashion as to like the Sherman
neck ties that happened in the Civil War
where they would like burn the railroad
tracks to stop the the movement of all
these like the food or ammo and stuff I
hope it doesn't come to that but at some
point I feel like they're going to try
to stop this from happening I just think
the federal points on federal highways
yeah or I mean I think the federal
government's next move is to say well
we're going to cut off money to the
states that are doing this that tends to
be their move to say we're g to you know
use the power of the purse to say you
get this but I think that again the this
has become such a clear issue and it's
winning over moderate voters too closing
the border is being against closing the
border is actually not a popular
position here's what people need to
consider so Ronda santis is sending some
troops to the Border again I guess you
know it's Florida State guard this time
so that can't be federalized gez imagine
if eight years ago someone came to you
and said in eight years 10 states will
have deployed law enforcement and
National Guard to the Texas border in a
standoff with the federal government at
the feds try to break barriers to allow
10,000 criminal immigrants criminal
aliens every day to rush through the
country and the states began to reject
Federal Authority the Supreme Court gets
involved the issue that I think we have
to we have to understand is frogs in a
pot boiling it's not literal but when
we're at the point
where Ronda santz a governor announces
he's sending a thousand troops to the
border which is in direct Defiance of
the federal government is trying to do
every day when something small happens
we get used to it at this point we've
already heard the news that 10 states
have deployed National Guard to the
Texas border now hearing that Ron's
adding more it's kind of like okay but
imagine how insane it would have been if
we went from 2016 to that moment nobody
would have believed this would ever
happen and I I can tell you because as
much as people like to say go Tim poool
talks about Civil War I kept saying this
will never happen this is not what
happens and here it is this is wild well
this is what I think is so interesting
about the showdown in Texas is it's kind
of this manifestation
of left versus right when the left has
the left seems to love the federal
government they they love everything
federalized they want it as big as
possible they want the almighty federal
government to be as big and powerful and
domineering as possible the right is
always very much about obviously limited
government but also the sovereignty of
the states and so it's really the
showdown between like the states and the
federal government and it is like a left
versus right thing I mean to this point
I mean that's it's just like Co again
with lockdowns yeah you know there was
people on the left who wanted the entire
everyone has got it shut down ruin your
life but then we had the States you know
decide thankfully for some people it
also reminds me of U the wave of
Governors that banned uh Tik Tok on the
you know on state or on State Property
State Technology and it was a wave of
Republican Governors I think actually
the governor of Nebraska let it off
first like two years early then Christy
gome bunch of this was the end of um of
2022 into 20123 but then at the tail end
there were like I think in total three
or four Democratic Governors that were
like yes technology is risky we have to
step in and say you can't access it
because you know part of their terms of
service means they can access
everything's on the computer or browsing
data so if you're a civil employee
accessing someone's private information
it's actually a big risk um but it was
right at the tail end that there were a
couple Democratic Governors that were
like okay we're going to do this too and
I I am wondering if you know in a couple
months that there's a a chance that you
know a more moderate Democratic governor
will say okay we're actually with Texas
on this one this is too risky to stay to
not be involved in WoW but it it's kind
of like the breakdown with law
enforcement too because you know the
left was screaming uh defund the police
ban the police like but they love the
FBI they they love the federal bureau
whereas you know conservatives are more
like we want law enforcement out of the
federal government like let's you know
they're Marxist they love when they can
weaponize the power against their
enemies all they do conservatives tend
to be more supportive or at least more
sympathetic to state or local police and
they are definitely more more
distrusting of anything on the federal
level where where are the
where's the law enforcement the
prosecutors from say West Virginia or
Texas why hasn't any prosecutor in Texas
filed criminal charges against Joe
Biden good question just outright and
let them argue he's
immune is he immune or not and let them
argue say look interview some CBP guys
Customs and Border Protection ask them
why it is you are facilitating human
trafficking why are you accepting
handoffs from cartels
and when they say just what I was order
to do you can go okay who's your boss
and then finally you get to the guy at
the top you get to mayorcas or whatever
and then you can say Joe Biden was aware
of this and we want to criminally charge
him how about you start with a Criminal
uh criminal investigation into Joe Biden
and let them argue you can't do it the
president's immune oh is he well I guess
you got to drop those charges against
Donald Trump is it your feeling though
that the average liberal or leftist
citizen is behind Joe Biden on this so
okay because my feeling is that this is
this is Biden kind of acting on his own
I don't feel like there's like a ground
swell of support from the average
citizen on the left not that I've seen
I've seen a lot of people who basically
put me in exile for things I've said
during Co come around to being like
agreeing with me on most things now so
but that's just me like I don't know a
lot of people I'm not in New York
anymore where there it's a hard thing to
defend people exist oh yeah I mean but
New York has been really hard hit by the
all the immigration stuff right I mean
again credit to Abbott him busing uh
migrants everywhere the thing is with
the New York the migrants under New York
and I can't remember the whole to Total
but at one point it was like 100,000
that had arrived in New York but he had
only busted like 30,000 there which
means that there were migrants coming in
already anyways he maybe exacerbated the
problem by not allowing them to stay in
Texas but it called attention to an
issue that New York was already coming
under siege for and that's something
that New Yorkers day today you know I
might generalize them as being more
Progressive than you know someone
someone in another part of the country
uh they are having to face the realities
of immigration the way that border
communities had to and so it is an issue
that I think is sort of undeniable and
ultimately there are a lot of reasons
we' talked about you know the effect of
the fentanyl crisis we've talked about
the effect of human trafficking human
smuggling there are a lot of ways to say
this is a bad idea if no matter where
your sympathies fall and I I'll clarify
for the individuals in the chat who lack
the capability to hold more than one
thought at a time uh CBP officers that
facilitating human smuggling and work
working with cartel members should go to
prison when you interview them and you
ask them why they're committing these
crimes against humanity and they
invariably just say I was told to do it
you now get criminal implications on
their superiors that does not mean they
don't go to jail but right now
politically the question is does Donald
Trump have immunity for the actions he
took as president and the answer is yes
unless he's impeached and convicted if
the Democrats think otherwise then the
political opportunity is file criminal
charges against Joe B
watch them come out screaming he's
immune and then watch Donald Trump's
question get to his his trial get
dismissed generally speaking
conservatives have not gotten wise yet
to the idea of weaponizing the courts
the way that the left has I I got to be
honest I don't even look at it like
weaponizing but the left is weaponizing
and we're not even there's no counter
reaction is what I'm saying the the the
anti-establishment faction is not even
attempting to enforce the law in any
capacity correct so so when you've got
Joe Biden destroying property charge the
CBP agents with destruction of State
Property that's a felony nope NOP no
we're not going to do that you hold on
someone gets an order to destroy state
property and the state's like well I
guess they're allowed to do it is that a
joke they don't they don't do anything
do you think it's be you just described
this as anti-establishment do you think
that's part of it they don't think about
how to use the system to benefit because
they are generally anti- the system no
no anti-establishment doesn't mean you
oppose governance it's just there's a
reason why the establishment gained the
amount of power that it did and why
we're watching them I mean it's it's
it's it's wild man it's it's a bunch of
Communists that are willing to say or do
whatever they want for power and then
everyone else just keeps saying leave me
alone okay well you keep doing that
they're going to they're going to keep
gaining ground wherever they can y I
feel like it I don't agree with it but I
feel like a lot of it has to do with
people being desensitized to the justice
system being so broken and having no
accountability on the left so when
people on the like look what happened
with like the the sex tape from the from
the senate or whatever they were like
we've closed the case can't find any
evidence of wrongdoing the staffer j6
getting you know all these all this
stuff put in prison all you know being
chased around
like we'll save this one for the larger
subject but the guy who filmed the uh
adult film in Senate no charges none
totally fine crazy well they can't find
evidence of wrongdoing like that was the
line there's literally a video of
wronging there's literally a video and
they're like we we don't know anything
anything could have
happened I don't get it but that I mean
I that makes people cynical and I think
that miscarriage of Justice or that just
sort of blind denial especially in this
case with compar comparing contrasting
it to J Sixers is interesting because
the more videos that came out proved
more and more that they were there were
so many people who were just waved into
the building I mean we had the shaman
who was escorted around th this idea
that there is actual video evidence that
some prosecutor has decided I'm just
actually going to turn a blind eye to
and in fact it seems like juries are
saying that doesn't count I think it's
beyond it's beyond that though because
we almost live in separate realities
there's people who look at those videos
and still see the thing they want to see
it's totally it's terrifying but I I
think you're right what you said about
the
desensitization of losing in the courts
it feels like we're always losing in the
courts and I mean to me even just based
off my own personal experience I feel
like there is a certain wokeness like I
I think that even the most you have a
jury trial I didn't sorry I cut you off
no no no you're fine you're fine no I
took a plea deal as most people are
doing in these cases but I did have a a
trump appointed judge yeah which did me
no favors trust me and and in fact I
would actually argue that in most cases
the people who drew the Trump judges are
they're getting the worst because first
of all I believe that a lot of the Trump
appointed judges actually hate Trump you
know just because they were appointed by
Trump doesn't mean they were Trump
supporters or Trump fans it just means
they have a history of conservatism and
at some point they probably worked in
the Bush Administration or you know
something like that uh but in addition
to that I think that they feel like they
have something to prove you know like oh
just because I'm Trump appointed doesn't
mean that I'm going to go easy on these
Trump supporters I'm going to go extra
hard on them watch what I do and I think
that's happening with a lot of
conservative judges around the country I
think it's another reason why we've lost
faith in the courts even if it's an
immigration situation whatever it is we
we just feel like we can't win yeah it's
it's there to Doom you who's your judge
Kelly her name is Dabney uh Friedrich oh
interesting I want to jump to this story
it's an old story but last night we were
discussing a video that came out from
the Atlanta airport that showed what
appears to be a drill sergeant guarding
a room full of illegal immigrants while
an NGO was inside that brags boasts
there facilitating these uh uh migrant
uh traveling around the country the
speculation at the end of the show was
someone said this is where uh people go
for basic training and so we do have
some updates nothing I can say
definitively but but if you were to lay
out all the pieces in this story it
would look like there are a bunch of
criminal aliens being brought into the
airport in secret under guard of a drill
sergeant potentially to be recruited
into the military I'm not saying that is
true it does also it's all it's entirely
possible that guy just happened to have
been sitting there that's right a drill
sergeant in the airport sitting in a
chair in front of this room full of
illegal immigrants just because he was
there and he was waiting for a plane or
something somebody reached out to us and
they said said that uh uh they may have
information and they think uh based on
what they know I don't want to get too
much into it for for privacy reasons the
individual may have literally just been
standing there completely unrelated it
may be that the room in question was a
Uso room that was allowing criminal
aliens to use his facilities and either
way this drill sergeant according to the
state senator who had his camera taken
from him was guarding illegal immigrants
it does not mean he was ordered to do so
it could just be he as an individual was
sitting in front of this room room
preventing people from interfering in an
operation that was smuggling humans now
many people pointed out to me that in
fact the US has been making attempts to
enlist non-citizens for some time we
have this from Stars and Stripes Senate
Bill renews effort to enlist
non-citizens in the military okay
there's been a lot of talk about World
War I we got this one from uh Newsweek
you love Dan crenchaw I believe it's Dan
crenchaw who said this talk of World War
III should not deter strikes inside Iran
yikes
okay I guess but there absolutely is a
fear that we are inching towards World
War III Germany Sweden the UK Australia
have all started conversations around
reinstating the military draft in fact
Sweden has always had one but they're
telling their citizens to get prepared
for war and now young swedes are
starting to consider whether or not they
will be conscripted in the UK a
high-ranking uh military officer said
it's time to train a citizen Army which
is cons conscription for National Guard
I guess you can call it in an Australia
they were having conversations about a
push to create a civilian Army to defend
the country in in if War were to break
out in the United States of course we
are facing massive shortfalls in
Recruitment and then you get this video
that looks like it may be criminal
aliens going through some kind of
recruitment process I say it looks like
I'm not saying it is take a look at this
from The New York Times this is a story
from January 5th 2024 to bolster
Russia's Army Putin eases citizenship
path for foreign Fighters he's to
strengthen his military to fight in
Ukraine while mobilizing a potentially
unpopular mobilization of
Russians if Russia is doing it other
countries have used mercenaries
throughout history I believe the
likelihood that the US plans to or is
actually in the process of using this
Mass influx of criminal aliens using
them for war it's extremely likely now a
lot of people said duh we've all said
this yes we've talked about that very
prospect on this show 6 seven months ago
but now it's starting to seem more like
a reality and I think we need me members
of Congress probably not going to be
Democrats have to be some Republicans
demanding answers and questions as to
what we saw in this video and finding
out whether or not there are plans to
use non-citizens coming through the
border illegally these fighting age
males to enlist them in the military and
have them fight in the event there's a
major a major war I'm going to say this
if you were in charge of a country and
you could not get people to join up and
you feared World War III was coming I
think most people would be like we'll
take mercenaries we'll take anybody we
can and I think this is one way they're
looking to do it it it just seems like
the logical path and I don't think some
people have said Tim that would mean
these people care about the United
States no it doesn't it means they care
about their home in Wilmington Delaware
it means they're like hey I got a
million dollar property in Santa Monica
and the only way that stands is if we
don't lose a war they will do whatever
it takes do you think the US would just
say well we're looking at a prospect of
international conflict we have a
shortfall in our troops let's do nothing
or do you think they're going to say
bring them all in
baby you so you're saying there's not
enough trans people joining the military
that they have to have to do this
because I wasr diversity was yeah I I
thought we were told that diversity was
the the most important thing in
recruitment right now no I I think to be
serious actually they probably they did
increase the amount of trans people who
did join the military but it wasn't
enough well it's not enough to bolster
their ranks but the truth is when they
offered uh uh the the the surgeries and
things like that there was a big push
from trans people being like I'll sign
up free free you know gender affirming
care sexation but uh outside of that yes
the wokeness in the military has utterly
destroyed it and so I have to wonder
then is it on purpose right because I
knew I knew I met a guy who was an
officer like an actual commissioned
officer who said I was going to be in it
was it was a career for me and I'm I'm
out I'm resigning my commission because
of all the woke stuff all the anti-white
stuff I can't be here now what's the
what's what's their alternative
either they're the stupidest people in
the world or they're intentionally
purging the ranks and then oh no we have
no choice but to to replace the the
soldiers we lost with non-citizens and a
lot of people think the purpose of these
noncitizens to bring them in is to
dramatically alter the electorate these
things are not mutually exclusive you
can bring in all these people say you're
going to go fight World War III and when
you come home you'll be a citizen and
then you dramatically alter the voting
body but how do you fight for a country
that you know nothing about and that you
really have no allegiance to whatsoever
how did the Hans how did any mercenary
group how many how many how many
military contractors in the Middle East
the other night surge brought up I think
it was Surge that you know during the
Civil War a lot of Irish were coming
over yeah right off the boat the musk
said go to war I think part of the issue
is you know yes they could literally
pick up guns and fight and maybe like
hear commands whatever else but what
happens afterwards like theoretically if
you're a citizen and you're a soldier
you get access to the GI bill when you
come back to the US are you coming back
with the idea that I have served my
country are you saying like cool now I
get some other benefits if you never
really acclimate to being someone who
feels a p like it's very different than
people who enlisted thinking this is
something I'm doing in service of our
country which I just don't think our
generation has really had I think it's
something that was in the past and I
think saying you know there might be
someone who says oh well I really feel
as though I served the country and now
I'm a citizen and you know feel that
effect but think for the most part if
it's transactional if you're saying oh
well I'm doing this so I can get in and
actually I'm going to not really
acclimate in any way I'm not going to
take on our a culture because right now
it's very hard to describe if we have I
mean I really don't think that there is
a unifying American culture that even
people who migrate here with the best of
intentions can seriously click into and
that's just very different than other
points in history including the Civil
War when there was sort of something
there that people were buying into I I
got to tell you if you're a conspiracy
theorist who believes that there's a
bunch of Global Elite want to take over
the world or whatever the best thing for
them would be World War III it reduces
population and it creates enough damage
and Devastation that it gives you an
opportunity to en enforce an
international governing body we've seen
we've seen this every time I mean if you
look at the Civil War Powers went went
from the states instantly to the Federal
Government after the war was over if you
look at World War II you get the
creation of the liberal economic order
if there is a World War III that causes
massive population reduction I mean a
lot of these population the malthusians
are going to be very happy but then you
have cities in disarray you have uh I
mean actually look at this way the NHS
the reason why Europe has nationalized
healthcare for the most part is because
of World War II after everything was
decimated and destroyed their economies
were ruined they had no choice but to be
like all these people injured and
damaged from the war need treatment and
so that's the evolution of it us doesn't
have that imagine what the world would
turn into if there was a ma Major World
War III and then From the Ashes the
powers that remain say if this happens
one more time there will be no Earth so
we're creating the global order
structure or whatever you want to call
it and all countries will abide by its
rules it will be based out of they'll
create some kind of military force like
the capital and Hunger Games I'm not
saying literally I'm saying an
opportunity for dramatic change comes
from war the reason the left would be
happy to get to Civil Wars because the
Constitution is gone the reason why the
world economic Forum Davos Elites would
love World War III is that it allows
them to completely overwrite government
bill like basically get rid of all the
different constitutions and guarantees
of all the different countries but I I
was just going to say in my conspiracy
brain I I've been like thinking about
what this a World War I would even look
like and I keep thinking like a World
War II is mostly drones and less people
right and so the conspiracy thing for me
kicks in where I'm like these people
should they become soldiers are going to
be used against our own citizens what
would the drones attack what would the
who knows targets like that have weapons
you know uh missiles underground uh
leaders of some sort but if the weapons
are all mostly drones the drones will be
used to take out infrastructure right
but they'll be like operating from like
a a ship out at Sea you know and then
what happens when you know you're in
you're in New York and all of a sudden
way up in the sky you can barely see it
a tiny Speck M fires a missile and blows
up the Williamsburg Bridge yeah but I
I'm sitting here thinking to myself if
you wanted to create a military that
really had no particular allegiance to
American people or its own citizens that
at any point you could turn on the
American people or weaponize against the
American people wouldn't you do it with
people who came to this country with no
particular allegiance to to the culture
to the country to the people that AR to
each other and enlist them in the
military and you know not just operates
federally it's not even like they have a
home state that they're like I would
like to go back there and be a part of
this community right exactly I I mean
these people would have no reason to say
no I'm not you know we're talking about
my parents my grandparents my the
country that I care about they're just
like okay big lessons from the Civil War
when the when the generals had to ask
themselves am I going to fight for my
country or my home and many of them said
my home is Virginia or my home is you
know uh South Carolina and they and they
left these people come in they their
their home is I don't care I mean I
don't know it's one place right so
imagine what happens if we get to World
War III I guarantee you if these strikes
that they proposing on Iranian targets
not Iran directly but Dan kencha
certainly wants it but actual Iranian
Assets in the region and this escalates
one step at a time until we are
literally in World War II before there's
not going to be a formal Declaration of
World War I Joe's not going to go be
like we hereby announce World War II and
let's go baby it's going to be one step
at a time we will find ourselves in it
facing a military shortfall which
everyone already knows about Biden gives
a state of the unit address saying
therefore I'm signing an executive order
under my powers in the state of
emergency to enlist noncitizens in this
country to bolster our numbers it's
basically Star Wars Clone
Wars you guys have seen that one right
no I haven't yeah you haven't no oh you
know guys don't get you don't know this
oh man well let me tell you basically
the separatists want to leave the
Republic and they they're blockading a
planet the Republic does not have a
military force that can stop them
Obi-Wan finds a planet that's
mass-produced clones
and they're like it's your army there's
an entire Army of clones available at
your disposal and so they go back to the
planet and they're like what should we
do and they're like if we use these
clones we can actually repel the
separatist so they say yes and then the
emperor says now that I have all these
clones who have no allegiance to anybody
will do whatever I say he says go kill
all the Jedi so this is quite literally
like the real life version the US
needing to bolster its numbers for a
potential World War III says we can use
all these noncitizens when that war war
is over and these people come back you
will have Stormtroopers who don't care
about you don't care about your state
don't even know the name of most of the
cities in this country and they will do
whatever the federal government tells
them to do and the federal government's
been telling them that most of the
citizens here are evil extremists who
vote for the
all hate yeah they hate you they don't
even want you here so if you were you
know to turn against them it wouldn't
matter that's why we held the curtain
open for you to sneak in and here's a
gun and come back with crazy PTSD from
whatever War we sent you to it's not
just the United States though mhm if if
the
US I mean and and I don't know the
probability of something like this
happening but let's say us bombs Iran
Iran immediately declares fullscale
mobilization US starts talking to its
allies saying guys it's getting hot we
need to make moves and then before you
know it within a couple months no one
declares it but missile strikes Air
Raids troop mobilization in Pakistan
it's heating up World War II Joe Biden
invoke you know invokes a state of
emergency gives a State of the Union
Address saying we need more troops the
numbers are not enough we will not lose
there are many he's going to say like
migrants he's not going to say illegal
immigrants he say many migrants in this
country love this country and will fight
for it and we are going to offer them
that opportunity he then creates this
massive military force once the
international conflict subsides and
there's mass destruction and death you
now have the opportunity for a global
elitist or whatever to say we can never
allow this to happen again therefore we
will be creating a a global governing
body to adjudicate disputes between
factions with an international military
force called the global task force or
whatever and it will be these people who
come from countries where they don't
quite care enough they leave they will
have no problem going to Europe to
Russia to China and so there will be
non-national military forces that's a
potential I'm not saying it's true I'm
saying the dominoes are lined up as such
it could land that way it's not good I
don't like it no I'm so glad I have
Insurrection on my records so I like I'm
never going to be forced to enlist like
though it can't happen I used to be able
to play the gay card but that's no good
anymore not the Insurrection card but
how old are you 47 you're too old come
on I I'm too old I I committed
Insurrection and well I'm gay but did
you did you think that it would be that
Insurrection would get you out of the
army and and not gay I I never dreamed
we did up here but it is funny that you
used to be too gay and they were like
actually we changed our mind like that's
fine you're way low on seity scale now
right right yeah right you're you're a
white male yeah and and uh gay is still
s heteronormative I believe right oh no
is it not it's problematic it's
problematic it
is I don't know man World War III or no
what do you guys think I keep thinking
well I kind of feel like we've been in
it and just not defining it as such for
a long time but I I was just going to
say I keep as way with all International
conflict yes right right I think they're
going to go back throughout time and
there's so many pockets of crazy
violence battles across the world and
they're going to in the future future
connect this all be like this is the
conglomerate of a war I'm just waiting
for like the Gen Z historians to take
over and be like we wouldn't call it a
war we would say it was a situation ship
we just we didn't really say what it was
so this is where we're at now from the
post-millennial Marjorie Taylor green
brings resolution to censure ilhan Omar
over treasonous statements I do believe
this story shows us the tensions between
the political factions I also believe it
shows um a lot of its for show I gotta
be honest
censure for treason is that a joke
everything Republicans do is for show
none of it it doesn't mean anything how
many of them have introduced articles of
impeachment against Biden right right
Democrats did the same thing but I mean
like dude if you actually thought some
had an impeachment trial we've just like
been like I'm gonna impeach you and I'm
gonna impeach you yeah if Marjorie
Taylor green and I I'd like to talk to
her about this but I'm going to say
right now if you genuinely think it's
treasonous I think the resolution would
be for a criminal referral in the
immediate and an expulsion from
Congress I see your point yeah followed
by criminal
charges for which the penalty is of for
treason is but I think it's 10 years in
prison or death right that's a bold
thing to claim someone scale I will say
absolutely yeah it is it's a wide range
it's like we're going to give you a
written warning for Tre but the right
the right is playing the same games as
the left like they're taking important
words and killing them right like
treason oh I know that's why I keep
getting mad when people say it's treason
I'm like no it's sedition right and it's
like I understand there's an overlap but
Biden breaking the southern border which
is bringing a bunch of random people
from different countries that's
destroying the nation that's seditious
that is destroying the fabric of the
nation right treason would be like he
met with an organized body that the U it
would be so it could it could be treason
right like if Joe Biden goes to the
cartels and says we're going to give you
everything you everything you want
that's a traitor to this country yes
they have betrayed the country to our
enemies right there's an overlap thought
I get it but yeah but no like Benedict
Arnold was selling West Point to the
Brit to the British you know they caught
they caught the one guy and they hang
that guy uh and and Arnold got away and
they put him in a nice uh grave in the
bottom of a cathedral and in BR all I'm
hearing is like this Scooby-Doo like and
I would have gotten away with it
too well there's also uh Ben Franklin's
son you know Ian Ian brought this up he
was a loyalist and he he fled to I
believe he fled to London where he was
like those people are nuts yeah yeah
it's crazy it's wild what what Benedict
got away with a lot of stuff and um you
know he was married to a loyalist and he
was a a war vet who was he felt like he
wasn't awarded enough from his time at
Battle and so he just like I'm going to
sell West Point and that didn't work out
he said I live by my own rules goodbye
he He Turned West Point like the biggest
battle point of you know it was holding
down the Hudson River and he turned it
into a literal pig sty and then when
George Washington came by he was like
what happened here where's Benedict
Arnold go get Benedict Arnold and then
his wife put on a whole display crying
fake crying so they say so bened could
get down onto the HMS vulture and take
off wow it's crazy and he ladies that is
loal that's
treason right so right now you've got
cartels NOS human Smugglers and I think
there is an argument to be made for
treason but I I I think it's too strong
in that we're not at war with some
stupid NGO they're just committing
crimes right you arrest the people who
are doing it Biden's just not doing that
so I'd say that's sedition but again
more to the point I I actually I this is
really funny actually let me play this
video for you uh this is Gooding
represent here we go centuring
representative ilhan Omar of somal I
mean Minnesota okay Bravo Bravo on that
one maybe that's why she wasn't sure
what she was bringing up on charge or
she's like I just got this good line we
got to get this to the floor quick I I
think there is a question though and a
fair argument to be argument to be had
everybody's really mad about Ilan Omar
saying you know my president and Somali
and all that and uh
I mean there's a lot of people who are
like we will fight for Israel we will do
what Israel whatever they need you know
it is a holy land I mean there's been
politicians who have said on par things
I don't like any of them to be to be
fair I I'm not sure that any of the
politicians who have pledged support to
Israel have outright said that they are
Israelis who are serving Israel but they
have said like we will give them what
whatever they want haven't some of them
worn like the the flag or or even
uniforms
americ flag isra and so I mean there
there's a question of like hey man I got
to be honest I'm not a fan of any of it
yeah like I I don't like the us spending
all its money on on foreign countries
and all this Aid right and Israel gets a
lot of it yeah so everyone's mad at
ilhan Omar but I'm kind of like okay I
mean Fair Point what's your position on
is on Israel because like I think
Israel's a right to defend itself all
that stuff I think uh you know what
Hamas did is bad I think Hamas should be
wiped out all that stuff I just don't
like our politicians acting like this
country is somehow deserved of
everything we have to give it I'm like
well it's another country they're
entitled to their rights their natural
rights their selfdefense all that good
stuff I think it's a beautiful country
too uh that being said there are a lot
of people who are are adamant on
providing Military Support massive
amounts of money and fine if that's your
argument I'll listen but why be mad at
ilhan Omar who wants the same thing but
for a different country I to me I think
that there's just a general attitude
with her there's this ongoing sort of
rhetoric about uh a hatred of America
and our values and that things need to
change and that we're inherently racist
and we're inherently white supremacist
and things like that so I think when
someone like her shows an allegiance to
where she comes from it lands
differently than I think somebody who
actually has a love and respect for
America but
also wants to support yeah like I I I do
recognize there's a big difference
between saying something like Israel
will get our military support is an ally
in the region and being like I'm Somali
from Somalia and I love my president
you're like wait a minute yeah and this
country sus hold on team I feel like you
don't remember where we are right now
yeah like if someone in Congress said
that you know Netanyahu was their boss
or whatever we we'd take that that's a
step too far some people I gotta be
honest though there have been I think
Lauren might have been Lauren bobbert
saying something like it was a holy land
I I don't want to put words in people's
mouths but there have been members of
Congress who have said like this is the
holy land we'll defend it and we're
going to work with Israel to do so and
things like that yeah I mean I I've said
this a couple times but uh when JFK was
President everyone was like well he's
Catholic so his ultimate Allegiance is
to the pope and can we have that and he
had to give a public address he had to
you know preex putting out the threads
addressing things he had to give a
speech saying like this is how my faith
fits into my loyalty to America
ultimately I'm loyal to whatever uh and
so I think this question of who do you
answer to ultimately is interesting
because we need our politicians to say
my priority is to the people who elected
me who are ultimately All American
although some of them live in different
states and therefore have their own
priorities uh the idea that someone is
like well my home country is Somalia so
I like it there better like K had to
come to West Virginia to earn those
votes from people who were very
skeptical of his Catholicism and he and
and he did win West Virginia and that
speech that you're talking about is
worth listening to No it's it's really
powerful and I I think it's it's
something that I wish more people would
study yeah she's Omar claims that the
translations were slanted by
propagandists yeah I've seen
I'm always worried about that when I'm
seeing stuff on Twitter like going viral
and they like and it's got you know yeah
yeah cuz you don't know you just don't
know and now with deep fakes dude yeah
when when someone's talking into a mic
and you can't really see their mouth and
this is all you know people you're
watching the camera and I you you could
you could AI deep fake
anything I show I showed Tim the video
of Joe Biden in front of a green screen
with the boom mic going through his hand
anything's fake remember that the that
was that was a weird video anything
anything is fake anything remember that
one where Joe Biden walks up to the the
Press Corp whatever and he and he leans
forward and then all a sudden one of the
mics is like in front of his or no it's
like under his hand yeah it kind of
looks like it goes right through his
hand it's just very strange I as if he
was in front of a green screen I think
he is in front of a green screen aot but
he does film on a Sound Stage semi does
do that as well he got L but there were
other angles of this yeah that looked
normal there were there were but I think
he's either a clone sometimes a deep
fake or AI that's just me I don't want
to Der rail the conversation Shane Shane
true I got to I got I got to stop dude
these these unhinged conspiracy have no
place insane conversations we're clearly
in a
simulation yeah thank you thank you Tim
dude I got to be honest like I'm sitting
here watching everything going on and
I'm like yo the world's crazy well this
is I've been think this but how do we
have that perspective like is it because
when we were growing up things seemed
more normal but now everything's just
nuts or are we just in some kind of
simulation I was listening to one of
your bits earlier about in the 90s when
we were all younger and it seemed like a
cheer your time the I I think that's
true it was true but there was more of a
curtain between us and degeneracy
happening in DC and you know outward all
all over the place there's no more
curtain anymore so the is everywhere it
was the the noble journalist who
shielded us from the harsh truths of DC
to let all the war mongers do all their
their Waring and you didn't have to know
about it I think we were a happier
country though were several decades ago
I know I don't I think I agree I think
there was a um a level of a lot more
stuff could get hidden things like I'm
grateful for media because it allows
certain journalists who I do trust to
bring things to like on the other hand
the downside is the degeneracy that
becomes trendy spreads much more I'm
hoping that that degeneracy starts to
Wayne soon that's my psychotic optimism
talking well there was an article in the
Atlantic uh that I haven't finished
reading so no one quote me on it but it
was talking about how there's going to
be a Christian Revival in America it's
already happening which I find fasc well
and and younger Generations tend to be
more religious I think there was a poll
out the other day and I don't have the
source that said jenz May males are more
likely to view feminism as dangerous or
bad there is a shift occurring but what
will be the long-term effect because
we've already you know we've already had
people raised in the culture of fear and
mistrust well yeah feminism should be
illegal uh women women should have to
wear those handmaid tail things that's
right
right wasn't kav supposed to do that
what happened to kav making that happen
I'm not why are you here Han clir he
overturn Wade they're going to agree
with you right the thing is that we all
have toe
that the cloak that they wear in
handmade sale the red one that's cool
that is stylish I mean being forced to
do I'm I stand by that 100% the head
thing I get maybe impractical for
driving but should women do just of
course all of those women lined up to
wear masks by the way and you can't take
them off their face like don't take my
mask away the same handmaid still but
then they have those scenes in the show
where they're like do we have to wear
these masks like pick a side piing about
all this though and like how we're kind
of becoming as a society numb to all
these shocking events that keep
happening I was thinking about that
crazy decapitation video that happened
that came out with the guy had a militia
did you write about it he claimed he was
president of the country now and he
wanted Biden kidnapped you know like
that's already receding from the news
and like there's no shelf life to shock
anymore like I think about my grandpar
because he's alive like he got taken
into alive which normally you'd think
they would film his appearance and there
be other stuff but I mean part of is I
think that he is just so crazy that it's
hard for even mainstream media to spin I
saw a couple like magga supporter does
whatever but right he ultimately
declared himself president so I don't
know super mad but even thinking about
how people are uh the theories fracture
after that video emerges we can't even
agree on that even though there's a
video of him saying these things there's
people saying literally he's he could be
MK Ultra which is very possible he could
be it could be AI the the head could
have been a prop you know like we can't
even agree on things in the video which
goes back to George Floyd you know any
anything on video January 6 all these
things so that's the stuff that's weird
the the break started with Trump I mean
it's it's if Hillary had won 201 we
wouldn't be here I mean we we would
still think it was the same country from
Obama and W and I everything changed
after Trump and that's when the break
began snowballed down like and then Co
happened yeah lockdowns well Co wouldn't
have happened if not for Trump
exactly some people thought the break
started when Kanye stormed the stage at
the VMAs and took tor's award so we'll
save that for another podcast that's
good let's talk about Taylor Swift
everyone in the chat fires me
immediately there are many things that
happened the biggest impact I believe
was probably the Great Recession that
shocked the entire system massively
which resulted in Occupy Wall Street
which resulted in
uh economic shift where what are young
people able to do without without these
jobs that were lost go on the internet
and start posting BS creating all these
digital news websites that make BS
creating a generation of people who
don't want to lift heavy things and the
big shift was around this time not
necessarily the Great Recession but it's
around this time with the emergence of
social media we got the rise of
intersectionalism and postmodernism and
it was because it made money that's the
simple version algorithms promoted
things that generate rage yeah if it
makes you angry it gets clicks more than
any other emotion and politics Injustice
makes people angry so the world is
dominated by politics since then the
avatar for that anger with more more
people seeing what was going on more and
more people being screwed over we get
screwed over in 2008 mostly the you know
uh genx and Boomers and
and then you've got Barack Obama and
what does he do he doesn't help you he
go there's more war in the second term
for Barack Obama people were unsatisfied
Hillary Clinton is deeply disliked was
advocating for war and Donald Trump
represented a lot of the anger people
were feeling especially young people
with the rise of postmodernism and I
know that's for a fact because I went to
like 30 plus rallies in the 20156
election cycle and I'd ask young people
like why are you here and uh Jamesville
Wisconsin was one me memorable moment a
fight broke out and this is such such
it's so indicative of exactly what
happened you have uh man this one really
grinds my gears sorry what what rally
was it Jamesville Wisconsin no for whom
for Trump okay so I'm there and I see
some young guys and I'm like you know
what are you guys doing here why do you
support Trump and they're like the
political correctness is getting out of
control they're like we like Donald
Trump because he speaks his mind and
he's pushing back a fight broke out and
you can find these videos I believe it
was Mike I could be wrong but there was
uh a young Progressive woman got pepper
sprayed what they did was they ran
headlines across the board saying Trump
supporter pepper sprays young woman it's
true but she punched him she she punched
him in the face he sprayed her
afterwards I believe that that's
disproportionate getting punched in the
face and all you do is spray someone
with pepper spray wow punch in the face
is way worse what did they do the
interaction was about one second the
girl punches the guy he instantly sprays
so when the these Al I believe it was
Mike shows this
argument there's a white Flash and then
he's spraying her with with with pepper
spray the white flash was when she
punched him they literally edited a
split second as if it was like here's
this here's the fight and here's where
he did it when in fact the whole thing
was a few seconds and they wanted to cut
out that she hit him first of course
this exemplifies exactly where we've
gone these these companies wanted to
make money we we also saw that Ryan long
bit where he's like I will sell
different footage to MSNBC or to Fox dep
on what happens and he's like if it's
you know when the protester is throwing
bottles at the cops I sell it to Fox
when the cops are attacking back I sell
it to M MSNBC that's the game so when
you get this you know Progressive woman
punching a guy no one's going to click
on that nah your audience wants to see
the opposite Trump's the bad guy so they
manipulate the media they they did that
so many times uh sorry to cut you off I
remember I was a Hillary supporter voted
for Hillary um sorry uh but I remember
during that time in 2015 and 2016 before
he got elected and it was like we were
constantly hearing these stories about
Trump supporters throwing black people
out and that's how and they would show
the footage of a bunch of you know Trump
supporters throwing a black person out
what they forgot to mention was that the
black person in many instances was a you
know kind of a radical protester who
often times was getting violent with
people they cut all that out and stupid
people like me like oh my God Trump
supporters hate black people they're
throwing them out of rallies why did
that seem so believable to you at the
time just because you were already in
sort of like Progressive circles or what
about it was was uh because I really did
believe
that so the you have to remember that I
didn't realize how big Maga was too I
don't think any of us really did yet so
the media was representing it as this
Fringe sect of the Republican party that
was small remember he was supposed to
lose in a landslide he was supposed to
get like 3% of the vote so I thought
magga was this radical sect of the
Republican party that was extremely
racist and bigoted that that was
reacting it was a backlash against a
black President Barack Obama these
people were it was a backlash against
gay marriage rights that were that
coming to the Forefront and it seemed
believable to me that these were uh
radical white supremacist people that
were being riled up by Trump the media
kept saying Trump you know calls
Mexicans rapists he's advocating for a
Muslim ban he wants to repeal gay rights
that's what I thought the movement was
about so then they go out and find these
moments that they could show me see
they're throwing black people out they
don't even want black people at the
rally and I was like wow these people
are terrible and it did seem believable
I think once they can the media
apparatus can convince people of uh a
caricature of someone rather than the
real person you can convince them to
think anything about that person and
they did that so beautifully with Trump
because they're like they present this
cartoon figure on the news deceptively
edited and then they'll tell you
anything and it was it was easily
believable I didn't care about Trump or
Hillary at 2015 or 16 I didn't even vote
the first time I didn't vote was that
was the 2016 election I voted for Trump
in 2020 um but I was like noticing early
on that they were doing to Trump what
they were doing to certain artists that
I like growing up whether it was rappers
or people in the metal Community they
were turning him into a caricature and
then people were going like oh it's a a
psychotic person you know but then you
know you see the deceptively eded videos
of good people on both sides just one
example and then you're like well that
illusion is shattering and then once
that shattered you kind of like there's
like a domino effect of all these things
can be they've been lying to me for
about everything I'm surprised we
haven't uh yeah yeah I voted for Obama
I'm surprised haven't more def fakes
already more what morees they're holding
on to those I think they're coming but
there's a certain I think like hypnosis
and brainwashing that that H like do you
remember growing up and being in grade
school and you you would learn when you
were really young if you're in trouble
go find a police officer find a fireman
you know and we were kind of taught that
there's certain institutions that you
trust that are just inherently
trustworthy right and I thought that
about the media like I did not think the
media lied I I thought you know if you
watch if it's if they say it on the news
it's more than likely true and when
Trump started talking about fake news
and all this stuff I was like wow this
this dude is the devil like he's you
know he's got this Fringe group of
psychotic weirdos that are following him
and then he's he's telling them not to
trust the news not to trust the TR you
know whatever right he was right about
everything I was primed for the fake
news because I was an a great as a
Marilyn Manson fan when Coline happened
and so I see the news saying immediately
Marilyn Manson is to blame for this but
I knew him as a fan being like that
doesn't seem right he just seems like an
easy target because he looks a certain
way I think that's an interesting
question like when did you stop trusting
the media when did you start to think
the media could Li you like that's a
very specific around grade but but they
still had a under a spell I think for
everybody it's different right because
if you know something is true like
you're fan when did you when I was uh I
was in Ferguson during the riots and CNN
I think it was Don Lemon I don't know
they said there was no tear gas they
were reporting that while I was standing
in a field of tear gas and I'm just like
wow so weird they they love it when I
was in the courtroom with Carri Lake I'm
watching them basically catch people on
stand lying against car Lake and then
the NBC guys next to me writing a whole
new reality and I'm watching him report
on it outside I'm like we started a
chant outside to mock this man cuz I'm
like this is ridiculous he's he's
totally lying I'm not surprised at that
point cuz was only wasn't that video I
can't remember what the reporter said
was it was this the mostly peaceful
protest video and like there's a summer
of 2020 and there's a a building burning
behind him and you're sort of like I
don't know if you understand the words
that you're saying right and and people
may remember too in 2020 my organization
walk away we went to Dallas we were
doing rallies all over the country uh a
BLM protester came to our our rally
charged the stage uh got taken down by
our security and the police came and
arrested the BLM protester then they
came and ared arrested our security
guard as well so my team and I they held
our security guard for hours so we went
to the police station to find out what
was going on when we got there there
were like 30 BLM activists outside of
the police station holding a press
conference everybody was there ABC CBS
NBC Fox telmundo everyone was outside
when we showed up these this is on video
people have seen it about 20 of these
guys chased us for five blocks screaming
they were going to kill us throwing
stuff at us taking our phones smashing
them on the ground all of those media
Outlets followed us for five blocks ABC
filmed all five blocks most of the media
Outlets filmed the entire thing that
night on the news they ran a story they
ran the press conference from BLM where
BLM portrayed themselves as the victims
of racial Injustice at the walkway event
mentioned nothing about what happened
even though they film the entire thing
Chappelle talks about in his last
special about when he's attacked on
stage by the homeless person and then
there's basically hit pieces against
Chappelle talking to the homeless person
and making him the victim yeah dude had
a knife and what you said a second ago
about Marilyn Manson I I mean that's
that's why they were able to get away
with what they got away with with Jacob
Chanley the the QQ on Shaman right
because he looked unusual so they're
like perfect he looks on you and the
left the left who so loves to be like
you know diversity and let people be
their own person and you know everyone's
unique whatever so you've got this guy
wearing paint whatever they're like he's
a weirdo get him get the weirdo made
know after a summer of riots and fires
and then this little thing at January 6
with a guy with a The Mask or the paint
on they but they will turn anyone into
the villain who ended up being the most
gentle person on January 6 and the
craziest thing I think about January 6
is the videos of guys who are clearly
Trump supporters who the first thing
they do is they go up and talk to Cops
and say what do you need us to do and
the cops are like help us push people
back and they're like you got it and
then these guys they're wearing like you
know military looking stuff or whatever
but they they go to the cops first
they're not fighting with the cops
they're like what do you need get these
people out and they go okay and start
telling everyone to leave and they go to
prison Alex Jones is on video saying
don't go in people tell me Alex Jones
told people to go in right what yeah
that's not ower goes to jail for being
outside at a permanent rally they had a
permit for what they were doing right
yeah it's getting crazy out there let's
jump to the story from sr.com shout out
to our good friend Anna casparian she
has called for the Asylum Seekers who
attacked police to be deported
immediately the story is wild I believe
it was five criminal aliens mercilessly
beat a couple police officers and were
released immediately without bail and I
sit back and I put my feet up and I go
well okay what's the problem you got
what you voted for well anyway now Kathy
hok is saying they should they should be
deported and Anna casparian said they
should be deported immediately I love
the Asylum Seekers I didn't know that uh
we used those terms here but I suppose
if it's true it's true Cas was
discussing a mob of Asylum
Seekers I wonder is it on purpose
Cassandra all like they all can be like
I am seeking Asylum thank you even if
they're here illegally I'll tell you how
I take it it's like taking the Asylum
Seeker the left likes to say and then
saying was a violent mob that brutally
attacked police officers you know what I
mean anyway they attacked two New York
cops in Time Square Saturday night seven
were arrested and quickly released
without bail the progressive YouTube
personality responded on her show by
saying that seeking Asylum here is a
privilege not a right let's see we have
we have a clip here I don't if it's too
long I don't want to play the full thing
if we can even get it to play Let's uh
let's do that and open it up on the old
the old X and see if it'll play there
these are not people you need to provide
cover for these are people who are in
the country claiming Asylum they don't
have a right to be here it is a
privilege to be able to take advantage
of our Asylum program and people so the
left is now saying it is a right not a
privilege uh anak kasparian is correct
and I got a couple things to say um I'll
stress Asylum is a privilege we offer
you and we don't have to we are nice
people I ain't got no reason to let
anybody in my house if I'm a nice person
I'll try and help them out the second
thing is congratulations Anna you
deserve these people because you lie all
the time so have fun I'll agree with you
on the political message I won't
disagree on what you're saying but I I
I'm not going to uh uh I'm not going to
provide defense for someone like Anna
who lies on her show particularly about
me and when the left comes and is mad at
her good these are your allies and your
friends so bend the knee or shut up
because I ain't coming your defense
she's got a point though I I mean it's
if you're once upon a time when people
used to come to our country seeking
Asylum it's because they were really
running from something that was like
life or death they were seeking
salvation what if you're Canadian or
Mexican I'm saying if that's the
situation you're in maybe on day one
don't come in the country and start
beating up police officers well if
you're Canadian or Mexican okay if
you're from Honduras what is what you
you go to Mexico MH you're supposed to
stop at the next country that that can
offer you Asylum instead they're like
we're just going to keep going till we
get to America like if you're dire
needed you don't just like continue on
forever and ever if if I'm if if I was
elected a supreme Chancellor the first
thing I would do is I I would
immediately B the gavl and say Asylum
only applies to people who come from
countries neighboring the United States
If you flew here my question is why did
you choose here sorry bye-bye if you
came here from Mexico and you said
here's what's happening we'll review
your case and I got to tell you this if
everybody who came here came to the
border and said I am seeking Asylum and
they were all Mexican I'd be willing to
actually bring them in and say okay you
can come in we'll find you a place we'll
set up a date for your hearing because
they're actually from a country where we
understand there there are political
issues pertaining to cartels people have
been killed and the number would be
substantially less the problem now is
they're coming from Africa yeah they're
flying from Africa to Brazil taking
these these a mult it cost like 10 grand
to do and then they get to the American
board and they go um Asylum and it's
like bro you passed through 17 countries
to get here right you're you're done you
were running from a burglar bro he's 50
mil away there's people in Yuma talking
about paying uh they're they're coming
across the border paying people to carry
their Louis vuon luggage they're flying
in weird it's very and this is the same
thing people fly into Canada and cross
through the northern border I mean we
did bring in a certain number of Asylum
Seekers after Biden's botch withdrawal
from Afghanistan right we had we said
these are people who we've now put in
danger they worked with our government
and we brought them here but the pro for
me the issue with Asylum and I want to
be as compassionate as possible is that
we are saying ultimately we're allowing
you to stay here we're not saying that
we're going to let you stay here for a
couple years and eventually when your
country stabilizes you can go back
ultimately we we're just saying this is
a form of immigration that we allow and
I think that's part of the misleading
narrative there's sort of this pretend
like ultimately you'll be reunified with
your country but actually probably not
you're just here for good we need to be
more honest about what the things that
we are offering the people who come into
this country are I just I just think
it's it's disloyal it's it's not good to
mislead the American voters they are not
that many Mexican citizens relative to
all of the other countries and so if
someone comes here and they can make a
legitimate let's just say a preliminary
claim we can say
okay right now what's happening is Joe
Biden's ad the Biden Administration is
opening up the gates destroying state
property and saying everybody just
whatever have fun and they never show up
for the Asylum they are not Asylum
Seekers that is just absolutely not true
and so this is still propaganda
anakasparian saying Asylum Seekers It's
not a right it's a privilege already
Shifting The Narrative they are criminal
aliens who have lied to exploit our
system and are committing crimes it is
not a right y'all can go uh put get the
ice buses and send them back to their
home countries they are not seeking
Asylum but the the the the side point of
course is anak kasparian has and
numerous occasions now along with Jen
Huger come out with positions that are
anti-leftist
probably because they saw the writing on
the wall I think The Young Turks realize
that you know the immigration issue what
was what was the other issue that came
out on crime crime and immigration ain't
winning you any friends yeah and so the
left is pro- crime and pro- illegal
immigration they are I'm not I'm not
trying to exaggerate they are they they
literally make sure to say be gay do
crime you're not going to be able to
come out and tell me they oppose it so
they're for it you're going to lose
elections I think uh Jen Huger and anak
kasparian want to win power for their
political faction
but sorry you are you are now your
political faction is is cohabitating
with farle extremists who want to see
the country burn right has Eric Adams
said anything about this yet like I I
I'm curious ien checked today I just saw
Hog's comments you know because he's he
he's been like surprisingly open vocal
about the problem with the IL illegal
immigration and he's been open about it
but also he I think should do more with
the county surrounding him so for a
while he was just in the middle of the
night bsing people to hotels in the
surrounding counties and it was the
County Commissioners there saying we
don't want this we didn't ask for this
you're the one who said that New York
was a sanctuary City and now you're
making it so it's our burden as well uh
and this was true I mean hok has also
helped uh disperse illegal immigrants
throughout the state and I think that is
sort of this interesting uh Dynamic
they've put themselves in you have hok
you have uh Adams who are actually
making it I mean I'm sure there's always
a little bit of tension between you know
more rural New York and New York City
but there is even more tension now when
they're saying you guys let us into this
position we can't afford or want to deal
with this and yet you think you have the
right to just say well all of your
communities are inferior to ours and can
serve our needs remember they were they
were flying in illegal immigrants
Westchester White PLS which is just
North for those who don't know just
north of the city what would you do
question for anybody if you were the
mayor of a city seeing an influx of
illegal immigrants build a wall I don't
know what you're the mayor of the city
yeah you're Eric Adams right now what do
you
do can you Deport everybody I mean yeah
that's that's my question I so like put
them on a bus and send them to Los
Angeles yeah you sh them back to the
Texas border uh I I think one of the
things is just because I don't totally
know what resources are available to
Mayors is that you would hopefully need
to have a governor who is like yes we
will remove them we will support you
because theoretically your local law
enforcement like if you're the mayor of
a small town you don't necessarily have
all the resources to say we're getting
you out of here you know for those that
have played Bal gate three there's this
really great scenario which you don't
need to know the game to understand
where um the game has three acts in act
three you make your way to a city called
balder's gate it's a city and it is
being besieged there's a war going on
refugees are pouring in and there's uh
right when you get into the outskirts of
the city which you could describe as the
suburbs I suppose there's a guy arguing
with squatters who are refugees saying
your house is empty it's ours and you
choose who to side with the guy who owns
the house who is traveling and comes
back to find his house occupied or the
squatters it's up to you there's a
character in the game named Menara she
is an
authoritarian uh I guess you authright I
guess she's a paladin who thinks like
she's just like a brutal dictatorial
kind of personality and there a really
funny moment where you talk to her at
the at the gates to the city with all
the refugees everywhere and she's like I
do not understand why they're not
allowing these refugees into the City
and then you can respond like wow I
didn't think you of all people would
would help refugees and was help them we
can use the labor and it makes me think
like it's something like that I'm
paraphrasing but it's really funny and
I'm kind of like I I I don't see
anything wrong with that what is wrong
with someone coming to this country and
saying please help me in Asylum and our
response being I got to be honest I
don't know or care if you need Asylum
you come here we put you to
work what what what's what's the moral
failing of that well I I don't think
there's a moral failing but I think that
already happens and I I don't think it's
a great system I mean no no no I'm sorry
they're un leashing these people into
into cities and giving them cash and
putting them in hotels I'm saying like
Okay what job can you do and we're going
to make you work I suppose the problem
is it disrupts the economy for uh lower
skilled labor in the United States so we
trying to make money for themselves
exactly I mean this is something that
when um if I'm remembering this
correctly when um Reagan and Carter were
were uh I can't talk right now when
Reagan and Carter were both running for
president uh Carter won West Virginia in
part because West Virginians were
concerned about the effect of
immigration on the country right the
places with uh lower skilled or maybe
union workers ultimately are the ones
who feel the brunt of it it's not people
who have Elite White Collar jobs who
feel the effects of of immigration the
same way and I think I mean Larry Elder
when he were here way talked about the
fact that uh inner city black men or
black communities are disproportionately
affected by illegal immigration because
of the disruption to the economy I think
Al ultimately you can also say that this
is sort of one of the like like I
remember being in high school and having
this conversation with someone and he
was like well you're not going to pick
food out of a farm and you want to be
like so you admit that you see them as
inferior workers you here to do
backbreaking labor fruit harvesting gets
paid like uh this was this was 10 years
ago I went to farms in California 15 to
20 bucks an hour MH no joke and they had
illegal immigrants working there I
talked to some uh young kids who were
skateboarding and I asked them like you
know what do you think about what's
going on there's these controversies and
they said their parents are uh
undocumented and so they were born here
but their parents they they work and
they're scared about what's going to
happen with Trump and all that and I was
like how much do you how much do you
guys make picking fruit here and they're
like uh like $15 starting but if you've
been here for a while it's like 20 bucks
an hour and I'm like I know a lot of
Americans who would love to make 20
bucks an hour just picking fruit the
other thing is that undocumented workers
or undocumented miners who come across
border if they're teenag whatever are
often the people who will work
undetected they'll be you'll see these
cases where it's like com big
manufacturing plant or Whatever Gets
busted for child labor and then
typically you can find out in the
release that the children are actually
undocumented in some capacity because
you know they're not necessarily
expected to be in school or whatever
else because they're not registered in
the same way that American sits are
meaning that they're not protected from
some of the abuses we wouldn't subject
our own children to I got it if I was
the mayor of New York you i' be doing or
Chicago I'd build a
pyramid like the Bass Pro Shop pyramid H
just a bunch of rocks you know what I
because I'm thinking like my question
about the moral failings of saying you
can come here but you have to work is
not about the economics which we we
understand we understand that disrupting
the economy is bad the question is is it
morally wrong to make an asylum Seeker
do work no no no I don't think so I
think you know if you come to my house
and say can I crash on your couch I'll
be like do the dishes and vacuum the
floors and you contribute and you can
say here like I'll pay the rent cover
the utilities you you you you Pro you
like we we we we trade right but what do
you do what what could Eric Adams do you
can't Deport deporting internally in the
United States means putting him on a bus
and send him somewhere else that's
basically what H was happening with the
santis and and and Texas that's what
Giuliani did to the homeless that's
right I got my neck of the woods yeah
but what if and and and you you don't
want to put them to work because then
they're going to disrupt low skill waer
uh low skill labor waer labor for the
people who live in the city so they need
to be occupied they need something to do
they oh I I say find uh some plot of
land just outside of the city that's you
know not being used and just start
building a pyramid guys so you're a
pharaoh I mean the the thing is the
pyramid's useless yeah it looks cool
though occupies their time makes them do
something and uh doesn't disrupt the
economy sick I think part of the issue I
mean beyond the economic impact part of
the issue is someone who migrates
illegally is committing to taking on the
responsibilities of citizenship and the
culture right and we already talked
about the fact that the culture is sort
of hard to Define there are a lot of
reasons that we don't have a strong
National culture right now but you know
you could say yes you can cut come here
and work but are you saying and commit
to our lifestyle and uphold our values
and and believe in our Constitution and
our way of government like I just don't
think you are I think that there is more
to it than just saying well while you're
here do something you have to be
committed to being here this is
reminding me of when I was a professor
at a community college in New York and
an observation I had was that a this is
so English for like uh freshman in
college and a a lot of those kids were
uh just came here from Mexico and hardly
knew English those kids worked harder
than everyone else in the class who had
been from that town and and they had
values like they were talking about Ben
Shapiro in class openly crazy ladies and
gentlemen we we've got a warning from
Alex Jones I'm going to play this clip
for you I have no idea what he's going
to say hopefully it's uh he's warning uh
about a terror attack let's play this
clip and see what he
says we've got a great team on the
border right now Chase geyser and some
amazing other people I'm not going to
say their names and they met with good
federal agents today who show showed
them the memo that they're saying
imminent white supremacist attacks in
Eagle Pass now whether that's a real
threat or not the point is good people
gave us this information it fits of the
whole Biden narrative to demonize the
American people and to try to legitimize
a totally open border and all the crime
and all the sex trafficing that's
happening so obviously we believe it's
probably a false flag there are some
actual crazy people out there as well in
this
whole crisis that America is in right
now I'd say 90% chance that yeah they're
they're probably provoking T but
regardless this is real Intel this is
real information we've got crew down
there right now we're reporting on it
all at infowars.com show I'll be on the
air tomorrow 11:00 a.m. Central on my
regular show uh covering it all as well
but our crew is down there at the border
and this comes directly from high level
sources so this is Major breaking news
that the feds have told the major board
Patrol facility uh there in South Texas
prepare for imminent white supremist
Attack On the Border Patrol so we're
getting this out ahead of time time
hopefully this exposure will stop it if
it's actually real plan I don't know all
the answers I don't know if it's a false
flag I don't know if it's if it's it was
false info from the feds I don't know if
it's a real I don't know but the report
from the feds and the memo is 100% real
so ladies and Gentlemen let's pray for
the board Patrol and others down there
and just thank God we got eyes and ears
on this we're going to stop this God
bless and good luck man I don't know we
do know uh in this story from dily
caller ice confirms it finally nabbed
terrorist allowed to roam free for
almost a year the guy who was in
Pennsylvania who uh beheaded his own dad
was known to the FBI yeah so I kind of
you know I kind of wonder about these
things
but I don't I don't know why anyone
actually aligned with Trump would go and
attack anyone down there I know why the
feds would stage something this is why
you know uh uh looking at everything
going on right now Trump is leading
CNN's projected Trump to win if the
election were to be held today for what
purpose would someone decide to destroy
all of that you're anti-trump and you're
anti-christian if you're doing that like
the guy with the manifesto with his
father's severed head he claim to be
Christian claim to be these guys are all
they they're they're not they're they're
not they're the anti that and they're
either I believe feds or
accelerationists who don't care and they
want to just see the whole country burn
so they can step case I think actually
insane might I'm still I still don't
know because he could just be ultra like
MK Ultra insane um that would still be
crazy though yeah no matter how he got
there but that would mean that he's uh
been weaponized by the government to be
in what what about the guy who was found
with all the weapons right in that what
was it like a a a par or something yeah
or he said I I I think it was a theme
park like I I don't want to do this I
didn't want to do this I just wanted to
come here when it was closed or
something like that or the guy in Maine
who K killed all those people you know
who was also yeah well the one that was
just his past fall I believe oh and he
was found in a like box truck at the
dumpster outside or something something
like uh but he killed a lot of people
wmart he was also at a mental
institution prior hearing voices then
let loose well there was that um uh
transgender identifying person I think
in Oregon who was uh arrested before an
attack happened but had been known to
the FBI posting all kinds of things
interesting case because the person was
both like biologically male identified
as female and also said that he had they
had been going to white supremacist
rallies with their now deceased
boyfriend it's very story my gut tells
me stuff like this if you are out there
being a part of this if it's going to
happen you are probably being set up and
it's a governor Whitmer situation where
like there's 20 people and there's two
of you and they're going to destroy you
and then use you to destroy the rest of
everyone everyone else or activists come
down and one guy they don't know shows
up because not everybody knows each
other yep starts it starts some kind of
conflict shows
up look at Occupy Wall stre what what
would happen and I believe it was
actually leftists that would do this I
know they actually had this in their
plans you find a peaceful protest again
far left we we would call them black
block Anarchist at the time now we'd
refer to them as antifa because it's
like the the name yeah 50 peaceful
protesters organize a rally saying we
want to we want to hold up signs the
left wants to radicalize them so what
they'll do is they'll have one person
dress up in all black go into the middle
of the crowd and then Chuck a rock or a
bottle at a cop the cops then bring out
orange netting and wrap everybody up and
arrest all of them then when all these
people you get some 22-year-old college
uh woman she's in jail crying being like
I don't understand I was just standing
there and then the person who
orchestrated goes you see how evil they
are you should join
us it goes back to what I was saying
earlier about caricatures if you can
convince people of car there's already
the caricature of the Maga extremists
Biden had a whole speech about it
they're the biggest threat this is
confirmation bias for the people who buy
into the caricature it's it's crazy and
I talked to a lot of people about this
and like whether my family who aren't as
plugged in to this world as we might be
and they'll be like how could you even
think that it's grotesque to even
question this it's a terrorist threat
it's a beheading this is awful it is
awful but when you know about things
like operation Northwoods that were
people like The Joint Chiefs of Staff
planning horrible false lags to start a
war with Cuba it makes it so I have to
question anything and I I know I have a
skepticism bias with reality and I'm
very like reluctant to believe anything
that's my own problem but you kind of
have to lead with that in times of War
which I do believe we're we're in a time
of War but what what is a white
supremacist attack I mean we talk about
this like it's a thing like we know what
that yeah they're going to blame it on
some type of contingent that they can
match up with the Justin moan type
character and anyone else from you know
j6 who knows and then talk about it and
being like they're going to go
Bama you know border patrol but in in
the last eight years and honestly
probably more than that there are only
two incidents that they can even
describe as a white supremacist attack
Charlottesville and January
6th and Charlottesville was pretty much
a nothing burger right uh so I don't I
mean why not just say uh uh border
radicals you a group of Border radical
because they've been selling a certain
narrative about magga extremists who are
white supremacists adjacent you know in
their minds and we might understand that
there's been white supremacist attacks
I'm putting that in quotes for those
listening but to them they think there's
been a whole slew of white supremacist
attacks this is the FBI saying it this
isn't Alyssa Milano I mean the FBI is
one like oh my God the white supremacist
are coming well what what is the I'm
start referring to leftists as white
supremacists well they are they legit
are but this is the thing we we we do
think they are segregation the speaking
down to black people the believing black
people aren't smart enough to get IDs
they're white supremacists the thing is
whatever our faction is we try so hard
to steal man mhm and actually honor the
arguments but that doesn't work for the
average person who's apolitical yeah so
you know let me just say that the kenin
are white supremacists I think they
genuinely are I think anak casparian is
a white supremacist I think she
genuinely is and I'm not trying to be
funny I think these people hold views
where they'll deny of course we're not
white supremacists but if you if you
were to bring up like is a black only
space permitted if you made they're
going to say yes and they're going to
make an argument that is overtly racist
they're going to be in favor of
affirmative action what does affirmative
action mean yo affirmative action at
like Harvard for instance this lawsuit
an Asian kid two Asian kids what the
left does is they look at them both and
they go they look like each other so
they're not allowed in school that's
racist that makes no sense yeah you
could get an Asian kid from South
Central who's like not the same culture
as a kid from from China but they're
just like but they look the same so
we're not GNA they're racist they're
white supremacists Mark Cuban is a white
supremacist Mark Cuban is absolutely a
white supremacist I will say this
unequivocally Mark Cuban I hope you hear
this you are a white supremacist you are
I mean he's even he's even reposting all
these these posts from people talking
about Jews thinking he's being clever by
doing it I just think the dude is a is a
deep seated white supremacist his whole
view is that so he he he Mark cuin made
this argument that if you have too many
white people you need to start asking I
mean this is this is a remarkable white
supremacist argument he made he's like
you run a successful business for five
years and you look around and all your
30 employees are all white so you think
I should hire a black
woman yo you're a white supremacist in
your mind the idea that you're
surrounded by white people with a
successful business I mean think about
where that starts what he is telling you
is his business succeeded on his
predisposition to only hire white people
okay let let let me let me stress this
he is he is he doesn't understand that
he's saying this what he is saying
projection is everything when someone
when someone says something to you like
uh I'll tell you I I I I knew this woman
who worked at Fusion when I worked there
and she said to me one time she's like
be be honest with me Tim like how many
of your friends like you're hang out
with the guys like how many of them are
are joking and laughing about like
raping women and I was like are you
kidding me none and she goes no no no
come on be honest like how many and I
was like zero are you are you for real
in her world viiew when she sees guys
she actually thinks they're all having
parties talking about raping women right
genuinely from feminist narrative Mark
cubin in his mind is
thinking businesses are predisposed to
succeed with tons of white people
working there I don't have that
preconception he's quite literally the
fact that he made the argument scenario
it's been five years your business
business is successful and you look
around and it's all white guys I'm like
okay what makes you think that's the
scenario to choose from that could be
you're in a majority white neighborhood
they exist
and then he immediately says I should
hire a black woman yeah cuz you're
racist you think that a black woman's
perspective is fundamentally different
from a white person absolutely yeah
that's racist soft bigotry of low
expectations I mean beyond that it's
it's the assumption that uh I shared
with him that video I saw this weekend
it's uh from Jubilee it's awesome six
black guys and a white guy all wearing
blindfolds and the goal is to figure out
who the white guy is and they can't the
the white guy talks and he's from South
Central they can't figure out who he is
they vote a bunch of people off they
vote black guys they vote for black guys
to be white they're like that guy sounds
white he's out I sent that to him I'm
like imagine you actually put on a
blindfold and tried to hire the black
women or imagine you looked at a resume
and tried to hire you wouldn't be able
to you might you might look down and be
like ah they went to school in South
Central they must be black and then a
white guy walks in you're like huh
because that the the the argument he's
making has nothing to do with it so
anyway long story short oh yeah Mark
cubin hands down is a white supremacist
I'm not that's not an exaggeration
either just because they're they're
doing the like uh um the royalty of but
we're so much better than they are the
lonely people need our help that's what
he's doing they'd be nothing awful
that's like an awful racist yeah they
they literally think that that that you
would they need you to survive yes you
should yes also somebody should clip
that segment cuz it was hilarious while
we're at it can someone make like some
pictures of him in a certain white Hood
perhaps Mark Cuban I think he needs that
on twit I don't know about
no Tim Tim's not asking for that that's
that's me just s those directly sh it's
better than the Pelosi AI things I've
been I've been getting so you're still
getting them because you love they slow
down they slow I feel like you're
seeking them out at this point you're
still getting them imagine that's my
thing H I just think it's interesting
that like when we hear terms like white
supremacist attack it's like we've all
become so conditioned to believe that
that's a thing but there's literally
like no precedent and no history to back
it up like when the mosis went out and
protected their property it was you know
BLM came into their neighborhood knocked
out they went out there because there
was an established precedent of BLM
doing that they knew what was up they're
like you guys are coming here to throw
rocks through window they broke into
they broke into their property right but
what I'm saying is they knew to protect
their property because there had been
weeks and weeks and weeks of this
movement going out and doing violence
and damage and and and uh uh uh bur
vandalizing property and things like
that we know what a BLM attack is there
was a reason why they had an instinct to
go out and protect their property but
what is a white supremacist ATT study
that came out from the ADL and I think
it was um it was I think their 2019 like
extremist report and the conclusion was
white supremacist is the biggest threat
to everything and they they were going
through all these examples and it's
really broad the terms they describe it
in you know anyone who has a white
supremacist tattoo Who's involved in a
crime that was considered a white
supremacist attack one of these examples
being a man who was involved in some
prison gang that's like white Su
Affiliated who with his wife wife
murdered his 2-year-old child and like
kept the body in freezer and they were
like that's a terrorist exam that's
example of terrorism or they included
the Parkland shooting because I guess um
uh I can't remember his name right now
but he the shooter had I guess maybe
drawn a swasa on something but even in
the report they're like this shooter
specifically said this was not racially
motivated and the police have never
considered it a hate crime so they're
inflating their own data just to say
it's real this is real trust us worth
white supremacist to defend your life
mhm how dare you it's to have an
American flag in the front of your house
or or to do this yeah you know like that
that's that's why none of this means
means anything anymore and why I keep
telling people like don't be afraid of
being called in names for standing up
for things that you know are logical
that's the thing that I think has taken
a really long time because I think this
fear of being called racist kept a lot
of conservative voices in submission
throughout the early 2000 into 2010
whatever else and again because Trump
got called racist so much and people
were like I don't think that's the case
I think that's wrong it started to sort
of fall apart but I think there is that
label I think that that fear of being
labeled or being misunderstood within
your community you don't know what the
social ramifications are is enough to
Quil people from from speaking out he
also wasn't defensive about it you know
he was he was called a racist for years
and years and years and people watched
as he just kind of like went on with his
business and did the next thing did the
next thing people started to realize
like oh maybe I don't have to care about
that so much maybe I don't have to sit
around worry because his behavior was
going to prove himself either way look
at his history he has happens to be
friends with lots of black people yeah
and he was in every rap he was in every
rap song that I wrapped for years right
they he was beloved by by everyone he
was made fun of because he was on a
reality show and he looks goofy but like
yeah they turned him into say actually
watch it the American dream is to be
Donald Trump did he really say that who
said that Obama said something like that
so he Adit so he endorsed Donald Trump
soft endorsement there yeah he should
use that for a campaign like why is he
not doing that
everywhere we need
this oh man is this a deep timer says it
was a
misquote
misquoted they're like disavow disavow
that well now we it say uh oh okay he
said something like that he didn't write
it was the American dream he mentioned
him he said Americans have a continuing
normative commitment to the ideals of
individual freedom and Mobility values
that extend far beyond the issue of race
in the American mind the depth of this
commitment may be some sarily dismissed
as the unfounded optimism of the average
American I may not be Donald Trump now
but just you wait if I don't make it my
children will so he admitted that
everyone wants to grow up to be Donald
Trump so so it's it's a paraphrasing
it's a paraphrasing of what Obama said
that so actually I think that quote is
actually apt he didn't it's not it's not
a literal quote Obama expressed the idea
that it is the American dream to be
Donald Trump that I I got I got to tell
you um Barack Obama said he hopes his
children grow up to be Donald Trump yeah
that's crazier can we get that quote I'm
going to I mean that's wild I'm having
so much fun with the AI stuff now that I
don't do it though but I think someone
should also create um Barack Obama with
little pump's Trump tattoo and we should
just PL that this is going to help this
is going to help like that that's the
thing that like bothers me about AI
which is that you know it's funny to us
in like the meme sense but ultimately
you don't know what someone's going to
twist and put out to you and be like
this is real I feel like I'd rather just
say everyone stop using it immediately
also bothers me because the more you
engage with it the more it learns about
you and that is how I feel I do I
actually despise AI I think it should
burn I don't like it I've never actually
use it although it's been so much fun to
do it uh through other people thank you
for whoever made that Taylor Swift tool
thing but uh yeah no I think you should
actually burn AI because it's going to
take everyone's jobs eventually well I
yes I hate it too but the reason why I
hate it is because now people can use it
to draft emails and things like that so
it's like when I'm hiring Staffing
positions and getting these really
nicely written emails which is very very
important to me I'm like you you if you
can't if if you have bad grammar if
you're a bad writer I'm like I don't
think this is going to work out that's
like a big thing for me so then you're
kind of fooled into believing this
person has skills that they don't have
and then all of a sudden you hire them
and you're just like you're an idiot and
you can't write how did this happen
facade facade there's and there's
artists using it to make art to do songs
you know I I genuinely think there will
be a future not too far away where your
favorite artist if I wonder if you'll be
able to differentiate their AI song from
their own song cuz they might shift to
just having AI do it or or they're dead
you know they they've been gone a long
time and the record label is like hey we
got this old Johnny Cash song here it
goes I like it at all well it's probably
we're we're well beyond that yeah we are
a year away from being like um whatever
your ai's name is Ian play me a new song
by
Tool and it will just autogenerate
everything in their Style with their
lyrical sense and presence and
everything and it'll just make a song
would you be interested in listening to
that song I don't know I mean it's one
one important thing people need to
understand is a big po a big component
of music is uh an attachment an
emotional attachment to uh Nostalgia or
or to the Past yeah so for instance many
of you may know a song you never
actually cared for when it's on the
radio but you've grown to like it
reminds you it connects you to those
memories the kind of music you like
obviously comes it's inherited it's it's
it it's it's you get it from your
parents uh this is why like they have
different kinds of music around the
world because you grow up listening to
music in your community and then you're
like I like this I like this feeling I
like the beat I like the time signature
I like the instruments and uh if you
were to play an AI new song you might
like the general style but will you be
attached to that song in any way well we
wouldn't but young people who don't know
have no past uh you know history with
music or relationship with music only if
the song is distributed if it's a if you
tell an AI to make the song who's
Distributing that song to anyone but you
this is something post Malone told Joe
Rogan about that that really is weird to
me and it was and it weirded out post
Malone that people could make songs by
him but personalized to them yeah so
then it would mean something but just to
that person right but it's him it sounds
like him and they're singing like he's
singing their name yeah I reject all of
that I don't like it at all so don't
make don't take any of my suggestions
Hannah Clair put me in my place you're
right have to be on guard about AI
always art video games it's over you I I
was talking about balers Gate 3 a moment
ago we are only a few years away from
Full procedurally generated world like
there's not going to be a GTA 7 or eight
it's going to be
gtii and you're it's going to be like
you're going to you're going to download
the game you're going to load it up and
it's going to procedurally generate a
unique game experience all the voice
acting automatic AI will just do it so
we're talking about the gap between
between uh what what are we coming up to
actually it is GTA 7 isn't it I'm not
sure what's the what's the new one
that's coming out is it seven six six
six is it really okay so then whatever
is there's not going to be the next one
the next one is it took so many years to
make this one that by the time they're
ready to make another one or planning on
even releasing one it'll all be Ai and
procedurally generated you're going to
tell you're going to tell the you're
going to boot it up and it's going to be
like what kind of character do you want
and what kind of scenario do you want
and you're going to say
1920s
mobsters and give me uh like I don't
know Godfather kind of Vibes and then it
will just make you your own game
storyline and everything in it makes me
want to hold on to real life things even
more than like it makes me want to go to
a concert with like people who love an
artists and stand to the crowd and hear
that song like it makes me want to turn
off the screen more because this that's
that's the only barrier AI really has
like it is contained to what you plug
yourself into it makes me want to buy
tickets to do things for now that's the
question I was just going to Poe to
everybody I mean like as technology
advances do you think it's possible that
we'll actually come into an era of like
a Renaissance of people who are like I
want to completely unplug from all of
this technology like I want to go
through back to a time where we talk to
each other and I have to go to your
house to see you like I could see entire
colonies like forming where people like
no phones no I do and I think you can
probably talk about this more but the
the first time it for me was this
movement especially among younger and
younger parents and it's starting to
happen among like Mom influencers where
they don't want to put their kids faces
online for a long time it was I mean
especially when social media first
started it was like oh here's my
adorable baby and do whatever but more
and more people are saying from the getg
go I don't want my kid to have to have
an online presence I want them to be
able to consent as adult it shifts the
the relationship and people are more
fearful of the internet I don't
necessarily agree I agree somewhat uh we
talked about this uh this story
treatment I was talking about the
members only the last city and what
happens when humans migrate underground
and all that stuff some people a lot of
people but 95% they're going to plug in
in 2 seconds anything you want you will
be
given there's literally no reason if if
you're if if the person says to
themselves man I long for a world where
we don't use these phones we don't play
these games and it was like the 90s man
oh well where are you going to get that
are you going to go get it in your farm
community you're tell when not to your
phones no you're going to plug in and
you're going to tell the machine to give
you to and will give you your world
where you can interact with fake people
and uh for all you know you're in it
right now it's funny cuz when I moved
down to West Virginia I was like I kept
telling everyone in New York it's like
the 90s here third eye blinds on the
radio every day you know it's amazing
everything felt like the 9s uh and and
but but there's still tell them the
secrets but there's pockets of the you
know people who are obsessed with the
internet everywhere and the internet
condensed the whole world into a little
small town I'm I'm not convinced I I I I
I know you have to uh I think in 2020
look at how radically different people
handled the shutdown there were so many
people like I love the shutdown I hate
being around people I hate going outside
it was like the greatest era of my life
and then a lot of people got like
chronic depression you know I'm very
much a a social person for me it was
terrible I hated it and I think that if
you're so I think it sounds very lonely
I think a very technological Future
Sounds incredibly lonely and I think for
people who crave socialization they're
not going to be okay with this they do a
lock that in New York people are Furious
and upset and they say don't worry plug
in your implant and you guys will be
hang you you will experience hanging out
in New York as if you're not in lockdown
and you won't know the difference and so
there will not be depression and
loneliness not just but there is a
difference there's a difference and some
people I think the overwhelming majority
of people will not experience some
people might be like it's fake I can't
take it I can't take it right most
people are going to be like I can't take
being locked in this box they'll plug in
the the world around them flashes as
their mind enters the digital metaverse
and in this digital reality they can
still talk to their friends it is
actually their friend that they go
downstairs they walk into the bar and
they say meet me meet me there at 7:00
they walk in Everything feels normal
feels the same they order a cheeseburger
tastes the same everything is
indistinguishable and then when they're
done they go all right man I'll see you
tomorrow and then disappear from the
reality and they wake up back in their
apartment instantly back home with no
Uber in the real world where they're
lock down well I got Oculus Quest when I
was on house arrest and I can tell you
it was not a substitute for going
talking
about I understand when they can
actually read and write to your brain
and you can plug in and physically feel
and interact with digital objects that's
going to be a whole that's that's a game
changer but we're going to go to super
chats so if you haven't already would
you kindly smash that like button
subscribe to the channel share the show
with your friends head over to
timcast.net L everything is sustained
because we have members who believe in
the show and like the work that we're
doing and uh me personally I am
sustained by my morning show which is a
separate uh separate show that I produce
uh 99% by myself if you like timcast IRL
if we're building a brand new studio
it's uh going to be done on Friday crazy
the whole building is done all of that
is made possible because of you as
members so I really do appreciate it new
skate show New Morning Show we're
getting conservative uh uh and and post
liberal and libertarian moms to hang out
and talk about news in in a Morning Show
St event that's going to be a lot of fun
and it's because you guys go to
timcast.net Wayne Mullen on the show yet
he's the one who tried to fight the
union boss I know that was hilarious and
uh I think we may have reached out to
him but I don't I don't know what
happened maybe I know that some people
don't like him
either the trooper says you need 50
doses of the vaccine to protect yourself
from Bob from what from the
Bob I just started I didn't read the
sentence before I actually did the
fouchy voice it's an exaggerated fouchy
voice but uh if you didn't know I am the
voice of Dr fouchy on freedom Tunes it's
in my my IMDb credits so I I voice a
cartoon Dr fouchy and it was really
funny because he's like as as he was
fading from the news like my my role on
freedom Tunes just dries up Sheamus used
to be like I got a script for you today
like please read this and just
constantly giving me scripts and uh he
he fired me he to let me go man yeah cuz
fouchi is just not culturally relevant
anymore and I and I beg Sheamus I'm like
Sheamus I could do other voices man just
let me audition and he's like nah he's
like you get fouchy and that's it
all right here we
go uh Aaron aie says never mask uh never
mask never ask a man his income a woman
her age and a Democrat what they will do
to stop Donald Trump
W Tim Jake is a busload of migrants
arrived in Colorado Springs El Paso
County Sunday yesterday County
Commissioner said the Colorado Springs
and El Paso County will not provide
Sanctuary to any kind of migrants car
springs is a fairly right-wing area so
I'm not surprised but but uh you know if
I was Eric
Adams and like I got to be ask like what
I would actually do if I was the mayor
of New York and these migrants are
coming in I would give a statement I'd
be like people of New York I just want
you all to to know that I will do
nothing in my power to deal with these
illegal immigrants I will literally do
nothing and uh I assume the problem will
take care of itself thank you and have a
nice day for real though the idea that
he's going to spend taxpayer money and
facilitate the criminal immigration and
the criminal aliens give them hotel
rooms and all that stuff that's only
making things worse the best bet is you
chose to come to a place with no
resources and I guaranteed you nothing
have fun and what happens they leave
that's it the local the locals won't
tolerate it the police won't tolerate it
no special treatment cops treat them any
other way get them out that's it go
home all right let's grab some
more free men Die free says when you
said Mr Bokus wet himself collapsed and
couldn't move I forgot we were talking
about bcus not Biden well he went he's
he's sleeping right now he decided to
leave the table and he went and just
he's he's
napping so he's still alive but it was
so what happened was
um he's he's losing a lot of weight we
he's been on a special diet for a long
time he's been getting a bunch of
medical treatment he got stem cells and
we have artificially extended his life
for over a year uh for those that don't
know Mr bcus is our cat and uh at some
point a year and a half ago he started
slowing down and we didn't think much of
it until one day he passed out and it
turns out that as a street cat he has
underdeveloped kidneys and a defect in
his heart it's CU from the streets and
so there's like there's nothing you can
do when the kidneys start failing it
happens to a lot of cats unfortunately
for him it happened when he was four he
is now five so he's made it quite a a a
ways and we're happy that he did today
uh he was given a little harness so that
he could finally go out and smell the
beautiful flowers there's no flowers but
you know it's it was 50 something
degrees I think the excitement was too
much for him must have elevated his his
his heart rate and then he just wet
himself right there and then fell down
and he couldn't get up and was just
hyperventilating and so he was giv space
giving some water and he got better and
then when we came up here to do the show
he followed us up and so we we
absolutely lowed Mr oh he's awake he's
hanging out he knew you were talking
about him yeah you know he can jump up
on the counter so that's that's like
four feet four and a half you know four
feet or whatever he walks around he
seems has no problems jumping up and
down but he's not running around you
know we got another cat named Sheamus
now Sheamus is a chunky boy you know
he's got he's got he's he's on a diet
because he's he's
chubby he he was a a wild cat we we uh
domesticated him over the past uh I
don't think domesticated him but we like
yeah I think it's the right word yeah
over the past month and now he just uh
it's amazing because he's about one year
one year old and he was living outside
he was living in a garage so we did the
whole Stockholm syndrome thing for him
now he just like lays on the couch with
his arms up like sprawled out just like
this is Paradise
so and he started like hanging around
your house I think he was ultimately
kind of test testing you guys out he's
like maybe maybe I'm supposed to be an
indoor cat these are cat
people Michael pepper says enjoy your
show and great guest and my kids have I
really like your music but can you tell
me when a country has changed with just
words I don't know what that means a
country has changed with just words and
in terms of the the death of language
that we're in and we use treason in ways
maybe we should oh right like when uh is
that what you mean so like when the left
changes the definition of gender yeah so
now gender and sex mean two different
things and what that does is it
retroactively changes laws because
they're textualists not originalists the
law says a person cannot be
discriminated on based on their gender
and they go oh but gender means your
self-expression and the Supreme Court
goes that's correct even though when the
law was written that's not what it meant
that's how they change change everything
uh that being said not the next song
we're putting out it's going to be the
end of February but the next song after
that we're going to make the same song
in four different genres sick and like
the goal is same
tempo same vocal Melody but
instrumentation like I want everything
to be as the same as possible but just
different instruments and like you know
just imagine if you replaced all the
instruments in like a weekend song with
like stomping on a stage and like a
banjo or something that' be cool so we
want to do something like that where we
write one song but in four different
genres and we're doing this because Tom
McDonald pointed out I think it's like
Nicki Minaj or Megan the stallion I
can't remember which one they released
eight versions of the same song that way
when they go to their fans and say if
you want to help me win buy all of them
and each you can buy eight songs and
that counts as eight purchases of one
one song on the charts it allows one
person to buy the song eight times
what's the is it like remixes VOC uh
instrumental Acappella uh no base heavy
Distortion like they you can do whatever
so of like people making music at home
perhaps and uh and also because of Tik
Tok now bands are releasing 2x speed
halftime speed yep it used to be like if
you if you look at old records you see
like a different version like radio edit
version beat mix version all these
different things that's what they're
doing they're using it to accounts
towards that final count that allows
them to get onto billboard ET ET Etc oh
the loopholes yep indeed yeah I think
the issue is because it this may be the
worst time for Tom McDonald to release a
song Because Nicki Minaj and Megan the
stallion are beefing they're like trying
to beat each other in the charts so any
other uh release week and they steamroll
right through he's like an independent
candidate he is the RFK of the rap game
right now however apparently according
to
billboard uh the three of them Tom
McDonald Nick Minaj and Megan the
stallion are competing for number one
wow so if everybody wants to see Ben
Shapiro have the biggest song and it's
Tom McDonald right Ben Shapiro's
featured on it shout out to Tom McDonald
uh
facts.com you can buy the song but I
actually I got to tell you this right
now if you haven't bought the song on
iTunes I'm gonna I'm G to try and say
this carefully and clearly if you have
not purchased the song on iTunes do that
we didn't do a promo for it because I
don't have a good way of linking iTunes
it's it's difficult but if you go to
iTunes download it sign up whatever it
is or if you already have it and you
search for the song Facts FACS by Tom
McDonald featuring Ben Shapiro buy it on
iTunes I'm going to say that one more
time for anybody who has not purchased
the song on
iTunes I can't I can't say much more
than that I can only say I will not be
surprised if it turns out on Tuesday
some dirty games were played to stop Tom
McDonald from succeeding and being
bigger here's the important thing okay
guys Tom McDonald mentioned how uh these
artists will put up multiple versions of
the same song Their song then appears on
the top of the charts the reason why
this is so important it's not because
Ben's rapping it's funny but a lot of
people like I don't care about Ben
rapping no it's because the
satanic music demonic music figuratively
and literally that they claim is the top
of the charts is not actually that
popular they don't have fans that can
that that like they do not have enough
fans to actually compete in this regard
unless they're pulling dirty tricks and
when Tom McDonald makes a song saying
our music like qu quite literally the
song the chorus is we're not telling
your kids to be thugs and your daughters
to be hoes we're we're we're we're
talking about important issues and our
music and our lyrics are good and
they're trying to keep that out the real
issue is the music industry wants to sew
far-left degenerate ideology to children
and they use dirty tricks to make it
happen and when you get someone big and
popular like Tom McDonald team up with
Ben Shapiro and they should be number
one I can just say don't be surprised if
come Tuesday some dirty games were play
I think the music industry takes
advantage of the Dead internet Theory
you know like I think that if you I
remember looking at Katy Perry tweets
and if you go look at the comments
there's a ton of comments but they were
all fake yeah clearly fake like
regurgitated the same thing sometimes in
different languages and I think like
they try to present this false Fame for
people This Is How They prop up people
like
Biden I believe uh Max Kaiser made a
great point and Stacy Herbert that that
when they were in Europe in uh 20 2015
2016 all they heard was Trump sucks
everybody hates him they can't believe
he's running and they genuinely believed
wow why is Trump trump even running he's
not popular at all then they landed in
the United States in North Carolina and
as soon as they got out and drove into
the suburbs they went Trump's going to
win because they saw Trump signs and
nothing else right the machine lies to
you to make you believe Joe Biden and
Democrats have popularity it's not true
I'm willing to bet even when you go to
like DC so I mentioned like I go to DC
like MGM National Harbor not just the
I'm talking about the whole area with
the the ferris wheel it's a lot of fun
you get dinner I'll meet someone who
will get angry no I don't like Donald
Trump what do you mean I actually
believe they do and they're just scared
that that they're scared of what it is
to be outed in public for for being a
trump supporter I'm in I'm in Chicago
and I've got a black shuttle bus driver
and he's and as we're driving he just
goes so who you voting for in November
and I was like and I was like well it is
tough right now and he goes just say
Trump and then I laughed and I was like
yeah it's probably Donald Trump the
reason I was going to say it's tough is
because of the primary right now and I
don't know if they're going to try and
stop Donald Trump so it's a nuanced
question but oh if you want a straight
answer like that dude I'll vote for
Trump you know absolutely and he was
like yeah I'm all for Trump man and I'm
like glad I'm glad you're not scared to
say this was Chicago and I'm like good
but that the media machine wants to lie
to you to trick you and so that's the
game being played right now
let's grab some more Super chats Jacob
Thompson says hey Tim something that no
one is talking taking into account is
the corporations that will move to stop
a civil war specifically the big Tech
data centers are everywhere and a
massive amount of capital is in danger
during a civil war in the orders of
billions I agree understand this though
Civil War is not a I hereby declare the
Civil War we say started with Fort
Sumpter if it really was about States
suceeding then it was well before Fort
Sumpter before Abraham Lincoln even got
inaugurated several I think what seven
states seceded from the Union and then
four followed after Abraham Lincoln
called up a mobilization to suppress the
rebellion and even then no one said
Civil War so sure big Tech might be like
we don't want this but nobody snaps
their fingers and declares it what
happens okay Florida deploys uh deploys
a Florida State guard to Texas they're
guarding the Border Biden says enough is
enough we are not here to destroy State
Property fight with you but we're going
to start processing migrants again and
we're going to find another way to do it
Florida State guard says we're under
orders to not allow you to do it some
shots are fired because of escalation
happens it's the middle of the night
people tensions are getting hot border
patrol screaming at these guys FBI who
like FPS shows up they're yelling at
each other saying back the F up now and
some shots get exchanged somehow in the
Heat In the Heat of it nobody's injured
everyone would say oh wow that was crazy
I can't believe that happened
following that Joe Biden is furious and
says I am going to declare I'm I'm going
to I'm going to invoke the Insurrection
act and deploy us Armed Forces to go and
shut this thing down now I'm in charge
soldiers show up Florida Texas Nebraska
these other states say back the F up and
then people think there's no way a civil
war is going to break out locals are
watching saying this is crazy what's
going on and then it does that was
basically the First Battle of Bull Run
it wasn't like either side said we
hereby declare fighting started because
it was a game of chicken so if something
does kick off in this country you're
never going to see it
coming the the the Americans in the
Civil War did not think it was even
happening when it was happening so we'll
see Majin Sora says if a civil war does
spark what side do you think the
millions of migrants that have come here
in the past few years illegally would
join uh that's actually a tough question
they may actually just fight wherever
they are I know we've said and many
people speculate that the feds and
Democrats will say they don't want you
here fight for us and we'll give you
citizenship but when it comes to like
the people in Texas yeah Texas is going
to say the same thing they're going to
say you live here and they're attacking
us and I think every state would just
say join up it's also possible that you
know especially if there are Enclave of
immigrant communities that they would be
like we're just going to defend our
territory and we don't want anything to
do with resv viw which is problematic in
of it in its own right wow cuz then you
have like groups that are just like I'm
not out of right right right y That's
the qu that's the thing about like
loyalty to wherever you're going you
want to you want to you want to join the
community yeah Jared Martinez says OMG
we are living the Star Wars a long-term
Senator becomes the leader of the
galactic Republic and uses a bunch of
cloned Mexicans to make an
Empire but they're not from Mexico these
people coming from all over the
world yeah but Venezuelan y That's H
people are getting wrong here it's not
Mexicans it's not just it's people that
are coming through Mexico doesn't mean
that they are Mexicans very easy to
mistake Brian Justice says during the
Civil War the Union enlisted around half
a million immigrants to fight against
the Confederate forces 25% of the entire
Union Army were immigrants while 18%
were children of
immigrants
yep endel Wayfair says IRL with poso
again dunk on his Taylor Swift cringe
culture War fight him well I'll just say
that
not to just get into the whole Taylor
Swift thing again it's ridiculous that
anybody even ever even brought up the
stupid scup argument I will just leave
it at there are people who are in
Congress in the Republican party that
you all know and love who are freaking
out that Benny Jack and others have
pushed this narrative and the the idea
is typic is generally they're sabotaging
their opportunity to get Suburban white
women by doing this
these people want the Republicans want
to go to Suburban white women and
convince them we are the appropriate
choice for your kids Lowden county is a
great example these are Lowden county is
a DC suburb of people who are like
Democrat leaning and slightly moderate
and then when they saw what was going on
in their schools lost it and and helped
vote in a republican Governor now with
the Taylor Swift scup narrative it is
poisoning the well so when these
Republicans go to areas like Lowden and
say what they're doing to your kids is
crazy and they go yeah but you guys are
screaming that Taylor Swift works for
the Pentagon like I can't vote for you
and so they're getting they're like stop
stop stop we're trying to win these
people over nobody's trying to win over
hardcore Libs in New York City they're
trying to win over like 30-year-old
women who are in the suburbs who aren't
very political but are concerned about
what's happening with their their
5-year-old kids going to school and
they're like what's going on so anyway
moving on that's something I'm worried
about with like I I think Michael rapor
is an idiot but like I don't think we
should I say that and I'm going to say
this I don't think we should push him
away if he's going to be saying I want
to vote for Trump you know we need these
people's votes to overwhelm the system
and uh you know I didn't think that day
would come with rapor Gand Gandalf the
Bas says Tim in new and old C Canon
Palpatine created the Clone Army and
manipulated the Republic to use it then
tossed the Clones to the side after the
war and replace them for Stormtroopers
Dems will toss when done I mean there
you go
right let's grab some more we will
scroll down where are we
at
Paul laoi lavoi simulation Theory proves
the Bible is true if there was a
beginning then there will be an end God
will prove himself I mean honestly I do
love simulis because you get these like
secular Tech Bros who are like it is
entirely possible that we're living in a
simulation and then my response is so
you're saying that like a more powerful
entity than us created our universe and
you see where we're going with this and
then you know you got to understand if
they really do believe we're in a
simulation then is entirely possible the
Earth is only 5,000 years old it is
entirely possible that dinosaur bones
were put there by God as artifacts to be
discovered it's you know I describe it
like when you play GTA and you're going
around Liberty City and there's a
skyscraper you know nobody in Liberty
City in the video game actually built
the skyscraper it was programmed to
exist that could be how reality works
too if you believe in simulation Theory
the Bible's not farfetched they start
converting Tech Bros by being like he is
the programmer of the heavens well for
real though like cuz Sheamus and I have
talked about this when I've talked to
people about simulation Theory I'm like
my friend I got to stop you there I
recommend you go to some theologians
Christian philosophers and Scholars and
and Jewish and and and even Muslim and
Buddhists because the questions you are
asking about simulation Theory are like
theology
101 did someone create us and create
everything we are in what is the the
nature of reality what is our purpose if
you're asserting the most rudimentary
thing that a more advanced species
programmed this thing yeah you're
basically saying that there's a
God I'm I'm I'm not saying there's a
single abrahamic God because in this it
would be arguably a Pantheon like if I
programmed a video game with a bunch of
people in it they would refer to me as
their God and their creator but I'm like
yeah but you know Shane's over here too
and I recommend watching a movie I think
it's called like the nin with Ryan
Reynolds and Megan
McCarthy yeah I don't want to spoil the
movie for you though but it's it's it
follows this General premise so I
recommend it it's a weird movie but you
know check it
out Sensei says okay Tim hear me out if
you run for office in the USA and you
swear your oath the Constitution we take
we take tour ring finger your ring
finger on your left hand to prove your
worth I don't what does that mean
what no idea I'm just saying I would
never be in office and if I was
I'd get impeached right away I'd just be
like dude I'm not playing political
games if bad thing happens bad thing
gets shut down or you wouldn't get
impeached based on the the current pace
of impeachments in the US government
Fair
Point all right we'll grab uh we'll grab
one more verus Lux
says all AI is inevitable fearing it
does nothing I am sure there are plenty
of people curse uh plenty there are
plenty of people cursing video streaming
and podcasts understand it learn it
position yourself to understand how to
use
it we talk all day about how social
media is making people depressed and
suicidal and destroying the fabric of
society and creating postmodernist so
yeah AI will be bad but my friends if
you haven't already would you kindly
smash that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show if you really do
like it tell your friends about it
that's the best way to help and head
over to
timcast.net I do we uh just relaunched
the walkway movement today uh brand new
group this group had grown to over
51,000 before big Tech took it down
after January 6 I'm asking everybody out
there watching to help me out by joining
and all you have to do Facebook yeah it
is and all you have to do is go to join
walk away.com and you'll be redirected
right into the group even if you're
somebody who didn't walk away You're
what we call a walk with support the
movement share our content help us
rebuild we've got one year to get this
right save our country go to join
walkway
join our group share our content help
walkway grow let's save America are you
on any social media platforms I am I'm
on everything um Brandon shock on uh x
Facebook uh I'm on YouTube but I never
use it anymore um and we actually have
our own platform too called walkway
social if people want to load our app
that's awesome yeah join walkway. comom
it's been super fun having you here I'm
Hannah Clair brimo I'm a writer for
cnr.com that's scanner news you should
follow our work at timcast news on
Instagram and Twitter uh I'm really
happy to to be a part of that team if
you want to follow me personally I'm on
Instagram at han. and I'm on Twitter at
hcbo guys thank you so much over to you
Shane yeah it was a real pleasure
talking today uh you can find me at
Shane Cashman on all the places online
uh my most recent book from the Inver
World Series is at uh ghost ofthe civil
war.com it's me looking for some lost
gold and getting in trouble with some
witches in a COV in in Georgia so check
it out new live Show's coming soon new
live show is coming real soon looks
awesome same YouTube channel I believe
right y yep we we will be launching live
Sunday evenings I believe um and it's
going to be a lot of fun I can't wait to
do that yeah uh I am on the wi view so
everyone is looking there hello I'm
right here I'm surge.com uh I did like
your new studio it looks sick and I'm
excited for the new studio in general so
let's go to the new show uh Tim let's
Late Show we will see you all over at
timcast.net